all right and we all love the last word
with law Cognito any Bartus fresh by the
campfire a lot of things going on or not
going on in the world of destiny EBIT is
mad what is gonna want you sir how are
you doing
Oh doing pretty good jumped into the new
bunker this week checking out the light
bright wall that we've got behind us
here and if you guys are listening to
the audio version of this the video
version has the background of the
bunkers with all the planets and stuff
going on and yeah we had an interesting
little cutscene so we've got a little
bit yeah teaser of the narrative moving
along we got the swab yesterday that
causes red and twitter to explode not in
the best way unfortunately and fixes are
also coming later for a very important
thing that everybody Joy's on the
weekends but at least this weekend you
should be getting it rewards because
last weekend bless so yeah so where do
we start in all over this crate do we
start with the narrative least the plot
start the positive start with the good
let's start with the positive just keep
it easy oh so when we logged in on
Tuesday we had probably the shortest
bunker clearing ever of all time of all
time yeah of three of all time so
dramatic but it was actually pretty cool
I wanted to get here and kind of
thoughts and impressions on just what we
got there right well first off I was
able to see it because I debuted on a
stadia actually was my new platform cuz
you're like hey I got this PC
master-race I got friends on Xbox what
why all right let me tell every break
down look that the logic here okay so
first off you know a PC master-race
right now because until consoles catch
up we got to stay without plus 60 frames
our field of view I get it and to Google
base some announcement this week that uh
the pro version of stadia is free it
sound like yeah any probably gonna watch
it you know
Utica me
if you like you know 20 up front or
something no actually it is legit free
would make a name and login you make a
name you date they do ask for your card
but they don't charge you until the two
month right so well they'll charge you
leave month then yeah this is here this
is your free trial and if you forget to
cancel you're gonna get you begin to
castle that's exactly yeah yeah but it's
what you do do you you literally do what
I do it you sign up and cancel and you
still keep all the pro features to the
two months it's a trial like oh let's go
that email was list I waited there and I
said look it look pretty good you know
I'm saying I can't front I did I had to
do my cross save set up my cross safely
it counts on bungee all that but um so I
think you know what you know what's the
best thing to do is to go straight into
PvP because my thing was one thing we
know about Google stadia service they're
not going to be hacked in the manner of
stealing you can't get access to that
yeah right so I said all right this
might be my trials hustle so I figure
you don't go into a little you know bv3
play list before before play list no
crazy you know mean they just proceeded
to wait and wait and wait I'm like
alright 30 minutes all right let me try
now let me try classic mix anyway anyway
II two hours
I tried four different playlists could
not get into one PvP I've still yet to
debut PvP on Stadium yet so I've done
I've done all what your car didn't even
a small population have you yeah so what
I was helping somebody else with some
things in the game
shout out in version if you're out there
and he mentioned he was playing on
stadia and was just trying to do the
public event was just having issues
trying to get it good like get it done
to get he called his people ain't coming
around to yeah that's a same idea and
then I went to go check the population
cuz I was talking to him I was like so
you got one point I don't know three
million usually and there's like 400,000
on PlayStation 380 on PC 380 on Xbox
pretty even mean it's like when you hit
over on Charlemagne and discord and it's
like 5000 across all of stadia and I was
just like wait that's and it's like
crucible has like 1k there's a thousand
people in the world you might get to
match with and it's just trying it's not
happening and it's like they really like
I'm urging everybody look it's free jump
it's like I have someone to play with
I just wanna play trials hack free I
just to see how it feels free for a
little bit everybody getting the same
amount of lag you get a little input lag
you get a little input lag everybody
gets a little input lag but you're on
dedicated servers yeah I mean I think
it's cuz I ran I was rather sacrifice
the input lag than the frame I figure
you know at least I had 60 frames
maybe my gun shoot a little it won't be
as responsive but it like hold on to -
it's like bad it's like it's like bad
voiceover from like old movies when it's
like if you got the speed if you got
listen I got like over a hundred I'll
hunt you down if you got to speed I say
go for it the experience is really cool
but again it but out of population I
mean it's just it's sad what's gonna
happen and I don't know what they can do
they've got to do a better job just
giving this thing away to get you know
the population up but all for your
visual fidelity for K it looking a shot
to do mental it looks good it's a shame
you know but um yes I did that so I said
you know what screw all the pvp stuff
let me go to the IO bunker and thus to
your original point I saw the cinema I'm
like okay so let's get into it
um yeah bet I was I was very surprised
that we got this kind of foreshadowing
we got our space Doritos are back and a
little conversation with Zavala and
ratsputin and you know looking like
we're gonna have a truce between the
parties what did you take from this
whole interaction so one Cevallos kind
of getting over himself a little bit it
was kind of the line is like you were
there and he was like when he has the
kind of the revelation in his mind that
he's like
lived through the collapse like we came
after the all guardians came after the
collapse I'm not a law expert so
anything I say today take it with a
giant aster so I don't completely know
what I'm talking about
but Guardians came after the collapse
when the traveler kind of like basically
hunkered down and sent out the ghost to
go find Guardians and stuff to protect
the area yes but like the traveler did
what it could to get through that and
the war mind was around during the
Golden Age and therefore also the one
who lived through this crazy time so the
vol against this like reality check of
like dude you were you got to see all
the crap go down you gave everything you
could and we basically failed like the
Golden Age has got done and gone so he
had that little revelation that that
okay war mines seen some stuff and like
what he's going for and he's like okay
so has this like little speech in the
end saying when the time comes after we
deal with the almighty we will prepare
we will give all our resources and all
of us together including the rescued and
we will be Guardians like working on
like you know the same line and I was
like cool speech then of course and then
of course the unlike Lance Reddick on
Twitter I'm just like yeah was he can
talk like all he wants dude I was listen
to that man talk he's got he's got one
of those awesome voices yeah his voice
unlike mine by the way I'm like thirty
dudes in the video game and Lance
Reddick because I am Zavala the
commander of all Tyson's and I am over
here I'm gonna be like Drifters but in
the corner so no it was it was cool but
also very ominous because you had the to
basically play backs of kind of like
sounded like black box recordings of the
two ships that were either being
attacked or basically being overrun
during the collapse yeah and it was like
multiple millions of people upon this
ship out towards Titan and the
arcologies being attacked and it's like
he's playing back that stuff and then we
get the map mm-hmm map shows up and
you're like I'm sorry what's on that map
yeah they're they're like is that a live
map
that looked like the Lavi so guess who
are like Oh Bo who can't see the screen
right now there's two please places now
well we kind of have confirmation if you
take our solar system go to Uranus
mm-hmm Uranus your I was trying not to
say that listen we got to be accurate we
got to be we got to be structurally
actually who knows just like not in
destiny by the way LFO it's just not
there yeah like a puto low J even have
like a little heart thing like Pluto
Hanuman heart on it anyway so you got
your anus and then you have outside so
in the projection we have all the kind
of patrol or the orbit rings and
literally right outside of that ships
like yes they're not that far yes
now I also be curious now this is where
I wanted to ask you a question - so how
much to scale is that map or the
projection because in that projection
mmm one of those pyramid ships will hold
yeah Mercury Venus Earth Mars every plot
like they're huge huge they are like the
size of Saturn they're massive so I'm
wondering if they are to scale now
granted one of them is sitting in the
moon is that like a baby scout or is
that like Independence Day mothership
type situation that's a good point I'm
wondering how big those things are
because that would be a very long
exploration for a patrol zone I can tell
you the question is I will say this um
with the way annual the annual Posche
structure has been going I am surprised
to see darkness references again you
know I'm saying like that this seems to
be a little bit more faster than I
anticipated still it's obviously we know
we got some reasons to is like it's
closer than we think or something
something yeah it's like mmm yeah at the
end of the day your black baby I gotta
stop you gotta relax it's just one of
the things that it's imminent you know I
definitely you know advancing this thing
much faster you know cuz I again you you
would think that this thing is gonna be
limited to the Almighty
and then after that maybe a hint of
something else but they're kind of going
ahead like they did with them you know I
was an old thing so yeah this is this is
interested I was very surprised to see
that we got our bunker did you did you
touch the bunk did you did you cash it
all your chips and have it all full is
it all done no it was done in the first
five minutes here oh my
I really logged in was like ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding was he every
time you hit the big guy you took a
Russian to you
Oh God constantly yeah constantly so
much Russian but I don't understand he
could be custom me out and I wouldn't
know difference so exactly very
aggressive Russian every time you catch
it it'll be really funny if like if this
is like translated and people are
playing in Russian they just do an
English system s of them he's in English
for mine but he's like actually like
formal English like so so how are you
today can you have some tea and crumpets
all the time by the way other or like if
they do if you see destiny and like
Japanese or something like that by the
way they have some of the best like
dramatic voice acting and be like yes
I'm like oh yes I would be very curious
how other things sound in other
languages absolutely that would be kinda
cool mm-hmm but yeah so we've gots so
yeah we go in the bunker and then this
is what's the background of our podcast
today and what we've got is some of you
guys may have noticed previously you had
like the big light bright wall and if
you don't understand that reference it
just means I'm too old you're too young
right but basically the wall behind the
bunker especially I think it's like
right behind the terminal of the lost
sector adventure button mm-hm
you've got what looks like a solar
system and everything seems to be lit up
and I've done some Twitter posts on this
one and it was like okay so you started
a big giant glowing or like half circle
as the Sun goes through all the planets
they're listed in Russian you have a
couple that aren't lit up you have a
belt so that is it lit up you have like
this Ling Kuiper belt and Kuiper belt
objects and then now this is like the
one where we can see far enough out
because the moon one has all this like
crap all over it yeah and then this one
we can now see all the way past the edge
of our solar system and just on the
brink of it there's these little orange
triangles sitting out on the edge so now
we have a projection showing pyramid
ships on the edge of our solar system
you have this little light bright map
that is also showing them as triangles
and late I think that's kind of where
you're calling it as well is right now
the Almighty is supposed to be on this
light collision course apparently it's
gonna take a minute to get here because
we've been doing this for like three
weeks I don't know what the travel time
of the almighty is but it's bit slow we
haven't even mentioned that yet we it's
like it started in the cinematic and
we're like hey we got it like Buddha
press butan since that little opening
cinematic though nothing like nothing
about the Almighty we have just thing is
coming and crashing through eventually
gonna come crash in the last city
apparently we know it's gonna be an 11
and a half weeks because we're gonna get
it right at the end of the season but
right now that's not a big deal so we do
have these bigger issues coming to us
mm-hmm he's like Prescott's like there's
a lot of space between mercury and tree
Arthur Berger I know I'm aware of the
black wings he said he thinks after this
next season the next expansion will get
a streamline to the darkness he said I
thinks all next year will be a bill to
it that's what uh you don't think we're
gonna get the ships coming to us
September okay so I guess that's the
question is what is the timing of all of
this stuff is what I'm painfully leading
to it's they're in a weird spot because
I ideally felt the darkness should be
destiny three and clearly we're not
ready for destiny three so I still think
they got beats that they got a tie-up
and they said we got Sabbath on we still
in deal with we still got Aldrin and his
foolishness that we ain't get to deal
with um you know the Queen there's still
so many threads that are just loose
still running around and don't get me
wrong I wouldn't be
hey if September's expansion you know
was okay here you're the dog that's or
at least you know they say they sent to
scout out and you know we got a deal
with it we actually see the REA whatever
but um yeah been a day almost in this
weird spot I don't know how they going
to reveal that when I feel the perfect
reveal of the race it's just by painting
would be destiny Bri you introduce a new
race you just a new subclass we go with
our theories of the light and the
darkness all the stuff we've been saying
and some of the rumors if guardians a
guy have to choose between light and
dark then that I think that's a goal cuz
that was um from the anonymous source
that was bright up until this part so
far yeah dark so um where's the non
denying whatever mm-hmm yeah but um yeah
that's what I say but the thing is
they've got a kind of stretch to me is
like they kind of got a stretch of dog
that's why I'm surprised
well we tuned it it is like oh there's
did not misspeak a shadow kyo like whoa
I didn't expect this you know here comes
season two worthy here we go again
so today maybe maybe you're right maybe
we get it maybe I'm wrong you're right
he's up to Merliah see that seems so cuz
a lot of everybody has been speculating
about and again go watch wife's videos
about this type of stuff because I
missed it yeah tell me about my son
mister I haven't finished it yet either
but I'm just saying if you want to catch
all the things law related it's like 16
minutes I just like oh part way through
and got distracted with like stuff in
the house apparently my handyman stuff
her in the house continues replace the
couple door knobs recently cuz you go we
have like a kind of just a bonus room
upstairs
just got him over the garage my wife did
yoga there like in the morning yeah you
were there I got to talk like she was
just doing yoga in the morning upstairs
and came down she was trying and I was
just like lay in a bed cuz I was
sleeping in and I heard the door handle
and it was like and it had recently
gotten kind of janky but was still
working and she tried to like get out
and she tried to open it was like oh
maybe it's just being weird second one
was like did it finally die and then
she's like help and I'm like because I
had to go open the door you see
literally got like trapped upstairs yeah
so it was like there was a trip out into
the world so Home Depot bought a new
door handle replaced that one so wasn't
that bad but it's a lote yeah see I got
that part done
mm-hmm but yeah it's like right now it's
kind of crazy to think like the timing
of is September gonna be it but I was
like as you were saying it's like as we
go through these seasons we had curse of
Osiris 2.0 we've had or mine 2.0 oh boy
no we're we going to get a forsaken 2.0
is one question I was very curious about
right is the Dreaming City is sitting
there in limbo for a limbo minute
yeah and we're going guys you feel we
got a that's why I thought it we still
gotta break the cycle and we gotta get
Salvador like it's it's getting to that
point now and we got it I think seven
through might be part of the darkness is
one of the big questions to somebody's
wondering like is the darkness the veil
savathun the bigger piece behind then
there's always I've heard that as
questions too right if you Scott will go
so Prescott rookie right now yeah so he
will definitely cover the lore so go for
it mmm-hmm yeah he says September's 5/7
hoon as she is the trickster I think we
start to see the first few Guardians
change and turn the seasons after that
will be the result of all the power
structures falling apart a new faction
starting to take advantage while hands
on the doctors taking hold so that 2021
maybe the line in the sand of preparing
for the war that'll be the centerpiece
for d3 in 2022 I'm filling the I'm
filling Prescott I think yeah that that
that sounds lit I will say this I love
that strike that you face and um it's
it's you as a violet and then Eris drops
in and she starts talking about Sabbath
dune and she starts talking about being
the trickster and she would only reveal
her hand
ah that's like literally one of my
favorite strikes back it's literally sad
no sidebar flashpoint Longpoint um my
second favorite strike is the arm the
other one the one in what was you gonna
go back and tell me the name of the
first one
alright that strike I don't know the
name is one what are you fighting the
taking in it you do it a lot of platform
you get to the end it's a cabal taking
boss and it's it's all taken it's all
yeah it's it's not not to shet lekha
shadows not the lake of shadows I was
like I got to add it it's and he's
another cabal take away literally I
think so because it is sivanna first
talking to you but then as the strike
goes on Eris joins the call and then I
was like oh Eris you best there in koi
yeah that's my fave I find out one time
but it was very cool I just have an
excellent like it never I never trip
into that one on accident Beatrice or
anything
I finally one time just picked it up the
map was like art I gotta see what
happens in here it was really cool what
a really old I did a really old mission
and that's that point where you kind of
going through I said I oh is that right
yes okay so and there's like no is it is
the strike on I oh yes yes it feels I
was laying the green hues yes yeah there
was like quest I was doing and it's like
that kind of half dome area with like
kind of the structures are at it I was
like oh this place is cool but I'd
actually tripped into that place for and
I was on stream doing some random quest
and then like hey this is the like and I
took a screenshot and put it on
Twitter's like hey this is really cool I
don't how old this is and somebody was
like yeah that's also part of festering
core was like I have to parently go play
that festerin core was like it was joy
like the size of that strike those your
zone be out right yeah go down you go up
and you gotta shoot the boxes then
you've got those grids like almost like
little laser grids there's a lot going
on with - I love that strike that's why
we that's why we like strikes write them
all the time yeah and my second one is
is nah Chris I've always been a fan of
that naka he pisses me off because he's
immune really yes okay cuz you would
have one phase no not that I just the
immunity phases of annoy me because all
it does is remind me of hollowed layer
okay and that's just like and you get to
a point it's like being like it's not
you can't nuke him or whatever areas
enjoy your drive to work safe drive
salute focus on job
mmm-hmm like nah Chris isn't a bad
strike in and of itself but just the
fact that you have to have to go immune
unless you truly do nuke em in one if
you don't can't nuke him but it's just
the mmm-hmm it's not bad I mean the
mechanics it's throwing the balls again
I thought it was a good thing so I'm in
the chain yeah I like that he's our
unique enemy like in a sense like I just
like the way he floated like he'll come
to where you're at yet he breaks the
barrage three phases on it yeah he's
stuck then he's stuck up there and
shoots at you and then third one he
floats at you and shoots you so low that
thing and tell me how much you like it
by the way so low that I want a night
[Laughter]
because my soloing days and I can tell
you there is one rock you can hide
behind that he won't go behind it and
find you it's real rough if you're
trying to solo that thing so I go bud
though it's go to sur alright so let me
let me flip it all you flash boy at low
point what is your favorite let's start
fair - what's he like what's your
favorite track what's the starting to
get exciting when he comes in I got a
look at the list hold on that's because
I feel like I'm gonna like forgetting
something serv says one of nothing that
oh you didn't sound gay someone come on
tell me what y'all name your favorite
strikes I'm Donna no I'm going I'm gonna
list them all off just to get a little
refresher and got the arms trailer Lake
of shadows mm I have a love/hate with
that strike which arms dealer I have a
loved it what it was an exotic that they
gave a cranked up version of it is so
annoying it wasn't decided oh that was
right that one is like the easiest one
to solo I know that one like him back up
that was the one I also showed you
remember that was the one I showed you
I'm trying to remember because I guess
the burn you could pick and void is
always a good one on there I was like
pull a trigger good thing good thing I
hate that he goes off far away put the
bubble up and all but only that's fun
that's another bubble moving him that's
a you know get him on the way up yeah I
like that now but that's actually like
that's one of those like
hey he's in
shield he's not just like I'm immune I
haven't mean like he actually goes up
there has a projection shield you got to
go break his shield he's like oh my
shields down I hop off go to the other
side let me do the other one
Oh broke both of those now I'm gonna
come chase your and like that type of
crisis climbing why this little floaty
guy that's cool oh no maybe just a hive
thing he just looks just like hi guys
yeah baby later cheb okay it's okay I
don't mind it but also you got to
remember now we're also gonna weigh in
with the nightfall loot so you got the
tilt so you got a sparrow on arms-dealer
cosmetics don't do much for me Lake of
shadows malicious birth right the first
kinetic grenade launcher it's kind of
kind of an important one saveth moonsong
that one's always that's the big
Shrieker oh that's a good one that's a
good one too solid Exodus crash well I
have excuse me I'm sorry I'm through out
there a little bit you must be the only
somebody in chat tell me if you like
Exodus crash because I'm pretty sure I
don't hate it obviously is that it is
that is that like a top three but I
don't mind it when it comes up I don't
get annoyed I mean I don't like it
discussed it but it comes stand on the
electricity played first do that while
you're defending that thing with all
that crap coming at you then you got to
go through part of nessus like half the
map and then when you finally fight him
more electricity floor I'm invisible
half the time I'm warping I'm all like
nah JA the data he said he loves it oh
but risk right on sheriff no zeref Dolan
you put that risk brother outside you
have it fun you could get a man and just
shout out the screen you put me a little
spot that you can hide all right guys
you don't like that leave that one also
has a sparrow
so there's annoying as it is the roar
doesn't great we've got the inverted
spire so that's the big drill what's the
boss big Prothean big the eye that moves
around no this is inverted spire this is
on necess
with the big drill it's got the three
tiers of the boss room about blanking on
this
this is like the beta strike for destiny
- that you played over that was
literally the first strike we never
played yeah okay okay got your bucket I
completely blanked out you know I had a
mind for this guy that was a cool run
through that was cool but you know why I
despised it because that was the debut
of um dual was it the primary marries
yeah and it just took a while but now it
aired now it's fun now it's better
I agree okay I don't mind you can melt
him you can melt him before he drop down
most people do anymore just later well
and then well he's toast all for helping
me out and that's the one when he went
to like giant mode do you remember and
he was giant yeah while pretty cool
we've got that's the that's the aisle
one so mostly a lot of taken but you got
the VEX boss in the end the sniper dude
with like the warping walls and stuff
yeah we got curse of Osiris we've got
tree of probabilities and we've got
right now in a now bias
I like trim with you like tree with the
Cabaye tree whether you got because it's
that a sit right that's the one you know
that's yes vagabond or modem which okay
garden world is the one where you ascend
up and you got the big Hydra that
rotates Peaks like you all that form
yeah it goes world tree of probabilities
is the Cabal bus in the end who like you
go his like the laser like three laser
rooms oh well you can melt him dough
before he get to them today can that's
it's doable yeah that's the DA view by
um my what's them boots the booster used
to Easter melt them crazy mmm Luther
factions we get him about it yes okay
here's okay
he said no actually I take it back
because you know I like that he's if he
gets to that room he's annoying oh he's
like he pushed in the back room I know
exactly how to screw with him there's a
little like you can just there's there's
the two sunken in the little lowered
areas mm-hmm and there's like kind of a
large lowered rectangle and there's like
a little like pillar in that lower you
literally stand behind there and you
either can like you jump up and he'll
like jump up and you wait
to jump up then you go down he'll go
down and you can just screw with him the
whole time so yeah see you know what it
shakes if for me he's always doing that
push off and knocking me off into the
straps coming over to go oh it's late
alright so then we got warmind we've got
strange terrain and we'll of the
thousand so you gots all well and not
Chris yeah I like well a thousand I like
I like I like what nah chris is
definitely on top I love and it's quick
knock which is a really quick strike to
if you really go through it they can be
quick inside were thousands inside
terminus that thorny fight car gun he's
the ass yeah he's the one you kind of go
through phases I like that one will get
the long Good Wife sniper from that one
then we've got forsaken got warden of
nothing so we know about obviously that
one that's that long the warden strike
with Weston would detect even check at
the end you she goes through data I hate
that that's my where I would not another
completely exam but for different
reasons I back all the way out with I
will not doing it that strike is too
long bro it is too long Jesus but all
right so you like know enough you like
that one that's the I never said that I
just said my brother hates that one with
you know I'm not a huge fan of corrupted
either because so what's the other one
so you got warden or nothing which is
the one of the prison we just had for
night falls that everybody farmed that's
three that might be a tough three cuz I
get to here I get to here oh I do friend
has arrived yeah I like that that gives
me president elders vibes you come down
there you get the fake out with all that
axes now say which you farm that thing
the fake out sucks yes cuz you're just
sitting there like all right I gotta sit
here in the prison room wait for it to
go through fall down let me get to the
bus like I hate those type of like
artificial time gate stuffs in there
talking is well Allah - like as that
does it's a pretty hollowed lair
mmm refresh brush me you fight the
fanatic in his little room are cool
good farming strike though I was gonna
say it has everyone's favorite farming
gun Mindbenders ambition is the one that
that yeah that's right it gets farmed
the most even if people absolutely hate
because he has more immunity phases than
anyone mm-hmm oh oh he's even more
growing now because now when you get
like you know like kind of warped in his
little like teleport thing that he pulls
his little tractor baby pushing yeah I'm
sitting there like oh you have to break
his shield for him to drop you literally
I was playing it recently we're breaking
his shield no shield steel teleport
again land BAM like you can't even lay
stagger him can't even says it's like
you broke it right so sounds like para
medium or garden price got lost God and
dad are you like the old Eli's I don't
know why of Prescott saying though I
don't like the corrupted people still
don't know the ball mechanic 100% true
people do not get the ball mechanic on
that one that's another reason why I
hate that's right yeah no that's
trust me corrupt it is it's got some
issues to it and the fact that [ __ ] is
least I got lucky but if you had to
grind out hores least on that one I'd be
even worse it's the pulse rifle and then
the other thing that came with forsaken
but I think was PS exclusive was bird
hold which we got recently that's the
two like which is that like split it's a
more recent one you have like feel like
you're like an insect larvae thing with
a with the gear it's that I would yeah
is that terrible is just you know so you
still give me no favors I didn't see
last couple all right a scarlet keep so
that's hash Lagoon that's it I like I
like that one that's a cool one and then
festering core we just got done talking
that's the like you know walls that come
at you as the [ __ ] oh no sound oh yeah
sure savage ones coming
so for me okay so what are yours you're
saying it feel sounds like warden of
nothing's up there
yeah was that like strange terrain with
knockers up there eh ways up there in
festering or the the dock that the other
Osiris was the other court warm with the
garden garden world guard world yeah
that I like take our ball in the giant
those like top four right there give or
take
definitely the rest of all good the only
ones like despise like I told you to us
damn yeah solo on my list Exodus crash
low easy corrupted low festering core
was cool but I think it may have just
been cuz it was new so I don't know
where I rank that one cuz I've only
played it literally one time and either
like yeah you haven't played it it was
like this it was really really cool it
will reminded me not quite whisper for
scale but it had like big long tear like
to go down have a cool mechanic walls
and that one was pretty cool like I
enjoyed just kind of the uniqueness of
that one scarlet keep was pretty cool to
like I'll be honest garlic keep it was
great debut strike for shadow key that
was like our only one though I'm looking
through Tennessee what I end you get all
that what's the one that when it comes
up you smile you get excited I gotta
hear that first off at the top I want to
know what's the favorite but at least
the two that when they come up you you
know yeah well by the put its apart I've
played so many strikes I don't know if
any of them do that anymore
seriously look at excite you you get
cold on it you sublease I mean I strike
like we know it's not a dungeon II yes
well know what I mean like we've played
them for years now it's like to be
excited about him is like a special
place when it first happen what which
one was and I'm challenging you when it
first came up you're like oh this is
cool
first time I played it or now either
thank you insane monkey with the sub by
the way just wondering what that's a loo
gotta like something
I was like warden's pretty much story
which wife warden is pretty cool with
the prison of elders because he got the
throw back even if I get annoyed by it
and I even played it as much as I did
recently it's those that like it's got
the trains which are cool because they
got the sparrows in there so exactly a
sparrow section to a strike which has
its ups and downs so that was that was
pretty cool I gotta be honest I'm gonna
play festering core like a couple more
times to be honest because that one's
pretty cool I will say like mercury past
garden world the one you're talking
about not even as much the bathroom
because that one gets annoying it can
get annoying whereby else ain't tell me
the ascent is fire honestly it's not
even the ascent it's like the opening
section
I just love past mercury all it's
beautifully aesthetic of that like the
walls like you laid
keep it going oh give a girl like I like
what you keep talking about it because
it's tones bright colors right it's a it
just it's very vibrant and in in the
flora and everything is living house
like in this is gonna be like this is
probably gonna be weird but honestly
like the the of the older strikes
especially in vert inspire and
pyramidion are both ones that that I'd
like for very different reasons like the
inverted spire you have like the giant
drill you're going across you've got
those like the scale of some of the
strikes like are strike inverted spire
is really really just the scale is very
grand like the three levels of the boss
room that's like a rare boss room that
changes you fighting him on different
levels very different mechanics in each
level as opposed to just like running
around and shooting you that's why like
that's why exit is crash I don't like
he's just like hey man visible I'm gonna
shoot you I'm invisible I'm gonna shoot
you in the room never changes inverted
inspire you have three different phases
of stuff like one you get a lot of X you
got the harpies up top down on the
bottom he's in the electricity outside
minis like marching up at you when he
gets all pissed off your blow his head
off like the the feeling of the boss
fights more and that's why knockers
doesn't do as much for me
because he literally just like he's
there and then he shoots you from there
and then he wanders and shoots you like
and all you're doing is throwing the
ball is to like break him through levels
but you have to do it every time you
can't be like ah hey I got through the
first and all this new come on the
second one you never get to new my peer
no you never get to do them weekend
unless you do in the first like three
seconds so yep where did you feel about
will love the thousands all in and of
himself is kind of cool but also it's a
warm God so it's kind of a letdown at
the same time yeah it's it's it I was
like worm God and then you're like and
then I just kind of like I feel bush I
beat him with conventional weapon now we
should have had to do a mechanic to beat
him yeah and the valkyries to into clear
abs but it wasn't required so I know but
I was like warden's pretty solid scarlet
keepers was an awesome one I think I
really enjoyed that one and then
inverted spire might actually inverted
spires cool for one reason because you
got the levels the pyramidion when I
solo that one on my own had a pretty
good little like kind of fist pump
moment to him as well because it was
learning to like the way the room like
shifts what geometries in the room yeah
then they're like little subtle things
so it's like all right so I know when I
hit him here I know when to run I know
and those little things for me like I
have very different thoughts about that
stuff of how I play them so it shows us
how badly we miss strikes though right
yeah I mean it's like yeah it's like
think about all those and how many that
you look back on you're like oh I do
remember that wouldn't even like Sabbath
oon song like running the orb and then
now you've got the ogre champions and
you've got the two Shriekers like I hate
the double Shrieker room when you're
trying to like run through the little
cutlet of Larry I did I tell you right -
it's so painful on a nightfall - yeah
but yeah it's also like arms deal or
like
you could hop up the chain get him to
spot early hang down at the bottom and
kill him before you get to the Select
there are there are a cool thing
about those and when you think about
what do we have now we have our bunkers
which are gonna go away we had sundial
which goes away yeah and that's kind of
a perfect little segue into one of these
topics all this like FOMO the whole FOMO
of content leaving not have anything and
that some people are saying I saw it on
reddit or something and they were saying
people aren't like cursive Osiris
they're like we're not saying curse of
Osiris was good but like it was for one
people liking it better than season of
the worthy which is so I did tweet low
somebody put curse of us ours better
this season to where I was like yo but
also like although we have all this but
left stuff in the game there's permanent
fixtures that are still there so you can
go back and experience them good bad or
otherwise like panopticon Asteria lee
wish that was a strike but not these I
wish that was a strike it's like the
McCain stuff like with him in there
probably wouldn't be a hard strike
that's why it's hard because of Cyrus is
in there helping you out you get a you
know travel through the two sides and
run the orbs and stuff but it'd be weird
but I agree it's still fun and I feel I
feel that freeing saint-14 should be a
part of the strike wait
the straight 14 joints did oh sure
oh by like they need like just only that
kill I I it pains me that some of story
missions are just stuck in that you know
I'm saying like those need to be pulled
over there strikes at my opinion I love
don't there's some really good story
beats man I would definitely definitely
think they should consider that man and
that into a strike pool since they ain't
giving us no new strikes yeah good just
let me go put like saving st. 14 in
there whatever you want to call it I
don't care but yeah the st. 14 mission
mm-hmm that was a cool fight
he's teleported in he comes out like
there are ways to probably tweak that
whatever you need to for like three
people in a match made strike it's
probably doable yeah yeah 100%
I like the bubble one - I like the
bubble one - bubble I like the bar I
like oh the bubble a mission gotcha the
bubble mission and I even like that was
it just like waves it was kind of like
wait there's like endless ways while
he's in the bubble when it's like
protect
you know yes'm protect me interesting
mechanic we just have this like infinite
bubble that you can kind of pass in and
out of mmm and they just kind of like
throw stuff at you but I agree I agree
yeah these are great missions that I
just like dramatics and I just wasted
because it's like you do them there
they're one and done so that's what I
call it a one and done so you really not
going back to it any other time but a
game and it's a shame because they put a
lot of quality development there really
well acted you know I'm saying it's
really good story beats that some of
those moments are epic destiny moments
that need to be relived yeah I mean you
it's like we give curse of Osiris crap
before it's like and I know I even did
too but it's like when you look back and
you think of like hey it's a mission
that turns into a strike yeah there's I
mean I would rather have that now like
you go through a mission like you said
saint-14 and then now that second one
especially on like future of X what it's
all dark and gloomy and like yeah the
big minutes are running around you gotta
kill him Saints calling out and I'm like
absolutely throw that in there
so dude I tried to get him to Camille I
got a I got a solo I got a solo Pitts
first and then I will answer that until
I do that's off the table I haven't sold
it I got to I'm blown behind so mmm I
definitely need to do that I've actually
thought about doing recently but I'm
gonna trying to play other things cuz we
are in kind of a slow time so at some
point I will work on soloing the pit and
then see it seems like now would be a
good time because we're likely
overleveled especially if they're gonna
introduce higher difficulties which I've
heard rumbling rumors of but generally
yeah mm-hmm there was a whole segue oh
the whole FOMO thing yeah so we have you
know we have the vex offensive which
that's that that's not really the one
I'm like hey striving to see in the game
right
but it is unfortunate things don't stay
around because you're like hey I'm gonna
go hey what's all this stuff going on
with Garden of salvation well there was
this vex invasion and then you can go to
the you know vex offensive and you can
fight the undying mind at that point
like okay
why can't the moon just always have that
going on memory because like but it was
like and they want and this is where
they get the whole you had to be there
type thing sort of mm-hmm but also on
the other side lit I mean that's kind of
why the whole annual pass wasn't a bad
thing cuz people go back and play the
foragers and be like all those were cool
they still can you can't go back and see
the corridors of time you can't go save
st. 14 again you can't go see what's you
can't even see the VEX public events on
the moon which were cool yeah that
animation this guy alone this guy was
five yeah so and they had Luke Smith
they'd say in the director's cut we you
know we lean too heavy into the foam oh
right so this is the question I want to
ask because we are talking about foam Oh
but at some point this world has to
evolve because it can't keep growing and
we know that right so with the pyramid
ships sitting on the outside
Leviathan sitting by necess what do you
think is gonna what do you think is
gonna go or get taken now to add say you
know you've got a Europa or a
dreadnought like what gets just like
nixed off of that director and replaced
by something what do you think we lose
to gain new stuff what's here what's on
your chopping block that's a good one
that's a good one
man that's a going arm because how it's
gonna segue be into more my my point is
about this which is I want it if stuff
goes away right which has got to happen
which you're making me choose that which
I think about but I want cataclysmic
loss I want I want to feel away like
when cave got killed what times ten like
a whole planet like like like um all
those necessary life you gotta come
swallow nessus up or you know attack on
you know Titan and Sloane gets killed
and I need whether the inhabitants are
there needs to feel the weight of their
area lost so that's what I need so I I
did we need so no one what do we pick in
here what are we picking
I'm gonna list them off for you Mars
mercury then you've got IO nessus Titan
II DS he's not going anywhere anything
and now in the moon those are and then
you got dreaming city entangled Shore as
well so I would hate oh dude I don't
think that goes until it's resolved
yeah we still got a result so I think
that's out um what are you doing nothing
on Titan blow that up
blow it out there blow no I will say if
I ever need to do like patrols and
public events though that is the easiest
planet to do those the easiest I would
not miss tight where do something would
tie a drum AZ dramatic we're not doing
that mercury talking or stop that you go
all you're doing is my brother Vance
Osiris isn't even there right now you're
gonna stop the brother Vance lance fan
Osiris bad brother Vance I just I hate
what they did to him but I do like but I
like old Fitz
I like Vance d1 man the more prophetic
you know disciple kind of guy as opposed
to you know so REM over there our
narrative writer Prescott says Titan
mercury and necess are all three I could
see from a narrative anyway yeah Titan
and NASA's Mercury I mean it kind of
still fits with trial so you can't
really get rid of mercury right now
because that's where say 14 is rewarding
you what and Osiris pops up every three
or four DLCs so we gotta leave leave me
alone zero on the other side necess may
be the one that actually goes because if
you remove one planet on that director
you actually clear out a lot of space in
the game you move me to go Boyd's yeah
you have all of those but that's like
your one raids do you like as you say
that they're enough I mean do you say
that unless they're planning to bring
the raids back like do you say like hey
if we do want to bring a raid into this
game we got to get rid of a parade and
apartment 2b and you know the penthouse
and the planet and the tribute hall
there's a well let's break it down let's
break it down lava the Leviathan is
ship rated something to ship yeah all
right all of it is to ship so in a sense
Nessus could go in a sense because
Leviathan houses the rates if though
it's just like hey so callous talked to
the Vanguard and for the ships still run
it has to swallow necess so it's gonna
be on the director just as the Leviathan
but necess is gonna go home and it's
gonna get pac-man's and then it's gonna
be gone so i misspell save everybody
cool sad miss feel safe still yeah I was
like even I hate Exodus crash but it's
like well anytime you're listening to
fail save especially to talk about Kate
it's oh yeah yeah yeah so that would be
that I think you can't touch the
eighties the I'll tell you what I mean
you can't touch it easy I don't think so
because that's where the I mean we're on
earth so until we're moving on out of
the solar system the gt's he's permanent
yeah Mars I don't think goes cuz of war
bind right now onerous your mind yeah
Mars is almost impervious because of
story beats yeah you know saying because
of all my you can't get it you can't get
rid of Rasputin's even though they could
do something cool and you know show you
the power of the darkness to get rescue
today I mean it would be very dramatic
be that they just did this season so I
don't see it happen yeah but to me I
just feel like whatever happens it has
to be a waited death we got to care yeah
I mean like hair does Abigail yeah
Katie yeah we are whatever it is it's
we've got to care like oh I'm not gonna
care about Sloane I'm gonna be honest
true so when you talk about having a
death matter any of the plane deserve it
are you gonna are you really gonna be
been like her over like ashram ear
that's mom and oh I know I know
but it was like he doesn't quite have
the staying because I've been PC for me
by the way yeah you're right it was like
he's not I was like trust me he's got
his like stick up his butt so much he's
like he's hilarious but he doesn't have
the staying power that makes him stay
around and like he does
he's like where's the dreaming city and
oldrin sorry that's the other we have
the ships but like I have to imagine if
the ships are like off in another galaxy
and now they're on the edge of our solar
system mmm way to go on like if they
made that far of a trip how long is it
gonna take for them to go from Kuiper
belt to earth over the course of like 6
months if they've made this journey so
far I'm like is it September now I guess
the question is is if that is September
if they're like ok shadow keep is a new
narrative screw all the old stuff which
is what which could be what they're
doing and then maybe late could be what
they doing seasons bring in like other
little stuff but the big like is you're
three for three
yeah three year three is shadow key and
we saw the pyramid ship we've got the
time travel now we're seeing like the
ship pyramids starting to come in with
warmind next season is game be the one
where you don't want to miss it you kind
of want to be there building into year
four is that when the pyramid ships come
and then if that's that whole arc when
we finally get them in even Paul TAS
he's like for the love of God get them
here if you read his article at one
point mm-hmm didn't you still have
dreaming cities sitting out there and
were like so I don't mean City but
dreaming city could still be handled
yeah you could sell Aldrin on his own as
an annual pass expansion you literally
could you could have him as an MPC we
all thought but in not looking good for
our predictions on him coming right now
but hopefully we get Reno wait did is
not looking good look at spooky right
for us right now but um and then did you
hear this boiler about this season about
who's coming yeah okay so we will not
discussed it but up so once I found that
talked about who talking about like your
about the previous game about a
character who rise of yes yeah I got you
yes okay okay okay
how made is currently disabled
I was being vague you just truly failed
at that one hey guys it's just this one
make sure we were to say pay it's this
one right here this picture talk about
it we haven't talked about it that was
actually the first time did you that
guess so we hadn't had a chance to talk
about those um those data mines and note
those those things so um you know well
we'll see but I agree I think that um
Aldrin is powerful enough for his own
season I think I mean there's gonna be
that would be one the scent of be like
all right well during a season two older
and cinematics team is like all right
I'm ready we're gonna have some crazy
stuff go down in the tower I am pumped
about this one Aldrin and Zavala and
then you're gonna have like aura walk in
and just go dude if not try and put a
nova bomb in his stomach like she's
gonna be pissed all Bob damn right you
guys are gonna find out babe why you
don't say spoilers and this is why I was
like hey the rise of that's pretty vague
hey that helmet that's disabled no
wonder what that one is in the game I
blew it out but it put like spoiler
warning in three two one
magneto spoils it here you go mm-hmm so
potentially there is that past like this
season which is also without spoilers by
the way um is gonna be a thing where
it's like maybe that's more of next
season coming up and that's kind of like
a rebus so it's like there's a lot it's
like reading a book and we can't flip to
the next page okay
like we don't know what's coming and
they have like three big options they
can go between re the spoilery question
the thing we just got done see on on IO
with the pyramid ships that's not
spoilers it's in the game go play
then again and then Aldrin potentially
with dreaming city and that cinematic as
because it's been like curse of Osiris
war mine 2.0 forsaken 2.0 would be
fitting somewhere coming up if they're
going in that cadence or the Dreaming
city
is not the big deal and it's the ships
if it's not one of those then possible
spoiler type stuff and it's like I don't
know which what would if you had to pick
one of those right now for so like okay
say season 11 yeah what do you think
season 11 and September what do you want
in September of those three oilerie I'm
gonna say something controversial um I
love you you just just say it and then
we'll decide if its controversial it's
got too much oh I want I want trial
psycho that's contrary easy
I built actually that's messing with you
anyways as much as I want Sabbath tune
to come and have not taken Queen Bing
part of me feels it's a rehash of
another September because we just did
shadow keep with her I'm tired of hive
being the ultimate big bad for the
expansion mmm right I think we king yeah
yeah we I take King here's the thing
Wendy to launch the big the big launch
was cabal they needed that shine right
cabal needed that level right I just
think that as much as I love destroyed
it'll be good
I've just we gotta give Eris and high of
a break for the expansion part and we
really got to dive deep with the other
races for an expansion level which means
we get strikes with me we get you know
what I'm saying so I and trust me I love
the how they're the coolest to do you
know saying but I think September or if
it comes I won't be mad but I'm like I
could see people who don't follow
destiny my gosh here they go again
another hive you know taking Queen and
just remix and everything you know it I
could see that Dara t'v you know say and
I kind of want some different bat
whether it be I don't know if fallen can
take it because they're kind of like
they're all dismantle they're all over
the place and then um
put it this way I wouldn't be mad if
Calais let's be real like countless
still needs to be addressed right
cows needs to be addressed we have that
really addressed this callous state
he's another like I don't want to fight
the robot the twin you know anymore like
it would be cool to say okay you know
what we don't hunted you down we smoked
you out
let's get you know to the bottom of this
mystery who are you where are you you
know let's get this going unless let's
do this for real kind of thing or he
secretly appeals as someone as the
mastermind behind you know I'm saying
something so um yeah Dan of damned Anna
was a loyal to you boxes leave now you
leave it a pie Daniel hey I see where we
get you back though I just want them to
pick another species boss for the basic
spaceship as opposed to even know
probably silent doesn't sir what do you
think
what are you big grand hopes but I don't
see it is the pyramids what I want those
as soon as I can get them but I don't
want specifically 7 through know what
the veil mmm you want the heading me
race yeah and that's what I'm like I
don't that's why I want it but I don't
see it in development time development
cycle a new race a new complete scale of
game dark light all that that's a game
that's d3 a that that's 53 and this
one's like that's the one that's not
what I'm probably gonna see but whatever
it is you're September still has to be
grand it's still big enough that it
won't be that big right like you said
but it's still a it will be epic it will
hold weight it will transform the game
on a bigger on a big level just as big
as three level but that's why I'm just
curious like what do you think I'm gonna
set a timer for approximately five
minutes yes we can talk about spoilers
for five minutes
hahaha because we have to for this one
if you don't want to know you can skip
ahead exactly five minutes and you will
avoid any spoilers leaks and other stuff
that have happened so we're gonna get
ready spoiler big spoiler warning in
three two one here we go okay so with
the spoilers we potentially have Siva
coming that's between the renders the
ornaments the transmat effects and all
that stuff you have the potential
rendered picture of people showing the
giant war mind with Siva down under
there we have possibly the idea of fell
winter who we fought and rise of iron
you have the potential leak this is all
spoilers guys so we want job yeah big
warning so you have potentially the fact
that we get felwinter's lie the ornament
is in the damn game his shotgun when I
thought Phil winter at the end of rise
of iron do we fight him again do we have
another bottle resurrection or something
so then the question is do we have Siva
in vault right so that's the big other
spoiler one is is Siva gonna be the
thing for next season or Siva gonna be
like the bigger invasion takeover or
like bigger issue in the fall do we lead
it or receive it like do you think Siva
the season 11 first Deva feels next
season ish that's what I'm thinking too
because I feel they're gonna lead us up
there cliffhanger us something happens
you know we get the fell winter but Siva
has to come back because that let's be
honest like Siva they've got new enemy
they've got enemy types and stuff that
they can use they got assets that they
could use no and that would that
wouldn't be stressful in a beating this
far in the episode anyway we got three
minutes we got to use it
so bro Siva splicers all those enemy
Titan from rise of AI and week we
sitting on stuff so we could we could
utilize that but this long yeah breathe
skin it's just a pretty skin
you know we gonna get that we're gonna
get we got to eat that but again we
haven't seen what where was rise of our
one three years ago two years ago okay
it'll be three in September it's been
enough to be missed and I would like
mama days to throw a little Sivir balls
at you you it'll be cool to see the
splices out here running around you know
so that's that um the affirmative runs
resolution so that would be so wet
season 11 right okay so say Sivan season
11 say that wraps and then then what do
you put in September if not the pier
it's got Simon moon goddess absolutely
has to be big
so some drunken city scale that person
not pyramids her thing like whatever
yeah so you don't so you think pyramids
are still later like you for d3 or year
five c3 whatever this Sabbath tune has
been manipulating behind the scenes were
so long
listen do that strike man that strike
they literally give you the playbook of
how she's going to be introduced listen
to everything Aris say I gotta play that
again
oh it's a it's an amazing loss right
it's she's like she's the manipulator
she will only reveal her hand when we
ready we better be hopeful that we're
ready what's the best actress that does
air she's amazing in that strike Oh more
liqueur and Dona yeah more Allah is
amazing in that strike please do that
strike again I love that it's a fun
strike - yeah but um yeah yeah I think I
think we do that and then we get when
you sneak baby shot the black wig maybe
we could sneak aldrin in and we gotta
get we got yes dreaming city oldrin
sabbath oon yeah all of that going down
for September you have seasons around
that the build slowly towards pyramids
in 2021 yes I mean that was our holy
before 1:21 but how do you play 20 21
September yeah I mean that's that feels
like y'all kind of fits yep consoles
will be out there'll be a year into the
cycle you know ps5 Xbox series X please
lives we next-gen only I know it does
need to that's one big thing we got one
minute then we can go back to that stuff
but um anything else boiler territory so
oh we've got one
we gotta get resolution on The Drifter
choice yeah we'll see if that actually
pans out I think that was like an
experiment I don't know if that's yeah
yeah do anything so what they they we
made a say in the literally the
narrative said it will affect a minor
choice in the game but a question is
when right when is it going to be
affected choice with light and dark all
the way down the road at e3 is gonna
carry over always it's still within d2
it's a good one
black will wrap the first second story
for the love of God with black wings on
that one like that I want it like the
dreaming city in limbo for so long kind
of hurts yeah for them cuz they but then
you go talk to Petrin she's just like
it's another week I'm stuck here forever
this is terrible like it sucks like
that's pretty terrible for him
alright 15 I was gonna say 10 seconds
shotgun good or bad do you want another
shotgun as a reward for this crazy
toilet thing at this point I'm
indifferent I mean okay so office
spoilers that was one topic we kind of
talked about in there so we're gonna
jump back in our feelings over the
course of the future of destiny kind of
sitting at that d20 what 2021 d3 hopeful
timing do it but know the next-gen
conversation you see the controller come
out we got series X Playstations finally
getting off there but luck and a little
bit by analyst go
but the big thing is mmm can they go
exclusive next-gen do you think that I
would I so what I'm doing they have to I
hope so
because it's like you got the new SSD
you got the atom body and the game will
be designed differently the game will be
designed different and then by then
you'd have a fear of um of development
time with the system they're the install
base of the next generation consoles
will be up more after a full year you
know I'm saying yeah I think you got it
do it you know I'm saying hey what you
do it you just you could you can bring
over cuz they're so good with cross a
right you can you bring it over your
account you know I'm saying you want to
stay over there
you know d2 is it'll be up for a while
to still be you know living nothing will
be getting up there trials in our banner
they just kind of suck it through cycle
through time man I think you care detect
is so vast to downscale it that's a lot
of work like it was actually as they're
kind of stuck
on any of 160 gigabyte game but it's
like that is the thing about next-gen
both have the SSDs and it's the
technology and speed that they can use
you don't have like hate picture the
Dreaming city you'll and I'm gonna go
drive through the cave to get to the
next area it's just an area there is no
cave there is no baby loading cave for
every sector every in-between little
area there's no in-between fake loading
places it just goes that's like I win I
literally want a picture cuz like things
like Uncharted Tomb Raider hold on let
me slowly shimmy through the rocks yeah
all of that stuff doesn't have to be in
those games potentially by the
description of what you know the
hardware is saying is lately I want to
see the games that are built off of that
row think about this six play the whole
the whole thing they were talking about
the other room or the PvE VP you know
I'm saying in an open space Guardians
and that's a giggle light versus dark
that's the big Oh light versus dark yet
like the potential is there but the tech
has to be ready and the tech to do it is
only explicit if they've got to do it I
think I think with them delaying things
and you know patrician things like
standing things out I think we got a
good shot they financially they could
pull it they still own enough platforms
where they can make their money you know
stadia you can launch d3 on stadia
doesn't matter it's in it's in it's
upgraded hardware there we go let the
strong servers for d3 SSO Joe Young rest
what saves them is them on PC now they
getting this huge base that prior was
just a console thing two consoles that
was it now you add what look at look how
is like the d2 PC base like number one
or at least two that's number two
PlayStation sit out there actually
honestly pretty even when you look
they're all in but yeah they're all I
think it's like PlayStation PC Xbox but
they're all relatively close closer than
honestly thought I figured yeah like
playstation xbox pc but pcs bigger xbox
is like dead even and play
stations only like probably not even 10%
above they were all really close
question this is the question about PC
mm-hmm if you're gonna make a game say
like d3 and you're gonna develop it for
ps5 you're gonna develop it for Xbox
they have an SSD at a minimum PCI 3.0
pretty fast throughput PlayStation has
it's faster one either way both pretty
powerful things your minimum system
requirements for next-gen games now have
to have an SSD with the throughput of an
nvme yeah and if you guys don't know I'm
talking about nerd out moment sorry in
advance
spinning platter hard drives and if you
guys don't know what I mean by that the
really slow ones that seem to take a
while to load those like literally load
your information at about 50 to 100
megabytes per second yeah you're a
little when I say credit card SSDs those
the ones you can kind of slide into a
ps4 those are fairly quick they're at
about 500 megabits megabytes forgive me
if I screw that terminology of bits or
bytes but that's like 500 550 usually is
about where those cap out and they're
not bad but a samsung you know 860 Evo
that I've got in mine it's like it's
cool but it's not that now in V amis
literally plugs straight into the
motherboard they run at anywhere from
two to three thousand and the PCI 4.0 is
sitting at like 3,000 4,000 5,000 6,000
megabits so we're talking like even just
from the credit card which were not even
on to the envy nvme you're talking about
six X speed so if you were actually
gonna develop a game that's gonna run on
the next-gen consoles which probably are
almost better than my computer and
mine's not bad right the system
requirements on games like that are
gonna be really interesting to see how
they handle that stuff because if
somebody's like hey you can play it on
PC and normally it's like you need this
CPU and you need this GPU to be able to
run this thing now it's gonna say you
need the CPU you need this GPU and you
need an nvme SSD with a minimum threat
like of that and I'm like that's really
going I think I'm like I'm not hoping
for it because that
check it out the way got a photo we got
an article up right now on Lords of
gaming that net and I'll put it in the
chat for you guys um it says PS 5
exclusive it's called quanta the gates
called quantum error alright and pretty
much one of the I don't know too much
about this game so I'm just gonna but
one of the features they're speaking to
the developer and one of the features
was um that it requires the SSD he has
five exclusive and PC and they saying
that it's not coming to ps4 because of
initially by that like it's going to be
a separate team down the road ETA almost
like what they did went um have you ever
seen like the 360 version of titanfall
and or like it's a completely different
game it's yeah they don't have like the
cloud stuff in it they don't have a lot
of different things in it it's that kind
of vibe I'm getting so if the developers
already on this mindset now I could
easily see that happening with the
next-generation console these SSDs are
night and day even the Xbox Series X
they're telling you yes you can put your
old games on the new SSD and play it but
you can't put Xbox Series X Games and
try to connect your you know your big
Western Digital over your USB at work
yeah that's a wrap so you can store them
on those but to play them yeah you said
it's got to be on the Seagate or the
internal same place it's got to be on
them in via me level hard drive and it's
like I am minding their conditioning us
right now that's kind of excited of what
that's gonna do my gaming Pro I love it
cuz I thanks to you getting me on PC and
it just gave me that taste of all this
I've been missing right I haven't bought
a PC in over in years you helped helped
me build out my rig
I get the rig and I'm like wow PC gamers
over my rig they would be I mean console
gamers over my rig will be losing their
mind right this these deuces blow my
system away it was like hardware-based
ray is tracing nvme SSD loading speeds
of just I mean that was the thing and
that's where I was like PlayStation Xbox
they're both going to be amazing this is
just an example run the conference a
PlayStation taking a cone of vision in
four
of you and just say it's like you know
peripheries about 170 degrees probably
not perfect 180 as you turn your
character
it's literally loading what you're
turning to in real-time because it can
really pull about 5 compress to like
uncompress linked 8 to 9 gigabytes of
information per second to like load in
as you turn so like I'm looking at a
house it's not that much in there mm-hm
and literally I don't have to worry
about anything I just turn and it's
loading as literally the screen pans
it's dumping that stuff into the screen
yes and then as I pay and that stuff
behind it's not like hey let me go into
a zone and look let me go through this
little hallway getting rid of that stuff
loading in that stuff none it's just
laying turn look run go in a house big
living room cool it's all here and you
literally run out of door straight
outside can you imagine if you were like
in the tower you ran down through the
last city and then just jumped on your
Sparrow to go in to eat easy just
straight through higher no stopping that
that's where these CPUs are really gonna
have all that open world constraints are
really gonna be alleviated it's gonna be
exciting Matt I can't wait for the
patches what he consoles just to get you
know patches for d2 right just so they
could even see what we experienced there
right now that we go gray when you when
you look across save onto PS 5 and
series X and you load up and you're like
you're just your eyes go like cuz your
field of view and like and then you're
like blown away by the 60 frames and
stuff yeah you'll never you won't go
back I will promise you once you're once
you have been tarnished by the
wonderfulness that is the greatness of
60 frames and high res and all that fun
stuff you won't go back so yep it's the
fact the fact and then can you picture
ray tracing and d3 that excites me
that's a pretty game cuz it's already
pretty right now it's already pretty
right now we got that man it's so much
it's so much Matt all these new
techniques you know our DNA 2.0 and you
know all the things you can do that it's
just the tools to make it easy for
development then they would alleviate
these issues that we're talking about
which is glad by the way sorry to cut
you know DirectX 202 ultimate is like
just what everybody's gonna use for ray
tracing I'm like I'm so glad it's
Universal so everybody figures it out
together so that's good mm-hmm yeah
mm-hmm
oh yeah that was all right just that
little thing no just don't like the rate
on ray-tracing being I have to mute
myself for a second oh you're good yeah
so ray-tracing itself is you guys may
care about it may not but it's just the
level of realism that you get like you
know you put a chrome shader on your
weapon you're looking down that weapon
it would be late kind of amazing if you
could literally like look on the side of
your weapon and then to the left of you
you see an enemy in the reflection of
your chrome shader gun like it's to the
point where the reflections are actually
potentially gonna be that cool if rate
tracing or real and powerful so that's
one of those like little tiny things to
look forward to it like I have a chrome
gun off to the left there's an enemy and
I can see him in there I can see you
next to me like that's the level of
detail you get and it's just that
immersion where accelerated rate rate is
gonna change a lot of levels that's
gonna be that guy
oh man you have no idea like I am so
excited and then just to hear both
consoles both Sony and Mark you
understand what's going on with the
pandemic but you know China manufactured
has come back online they do not
anticipate any delays that we're gonna
get these supplies are gonna be small
right off now that's where I'm an
agreement with Ellie how many did you
get well there's ten thousand for the
u.s. good luck yeah good luck like you
better get you pre-order on but also you
know who's gonna do it yeah yeah
shouting down Oh hallo look absolutely
blue beautiful ray-tracing they even put
HDR in games that didn't even exist like
to show you what it would look like when
a lot of these backpack it man I'm hi
you guys want to see what ray tracing
actually really does it is the stupidest
game to compare it in go play minecraft
with ray tracing or go see a video of
Minecraft with and without ray tracing
it is year like minecraft are you
serious it is the dumbest comparison but
as the like most like drastic comparison
that I have seen because you look in
battlefield and you're like hey I'm
looking at this truck and there's a
little water on the ground and if I move
I can see the reflection of like a
little bit in there but to stuff that
much minecraft is not the same the way a
little torch lights up an area in like
the darkness over here and the way the
Sun say it really like the
you know the Gadre comes down like the
beatings like coming through that's the
crazy stuff you're gonna you're gonna
lose it because you've really haven't
been messin with HDR so you haven't done
HDR for here retracing not bro is as bad
as destiny move on the Xbox because you
know the frames ain't it when it stays
still you a move it I know it's a really
good thumbnail it oh it's beautiful just
that when you move you in molasses
because they got they only do it 30
phrase but it is outstanding with that
high level that resolution it HDR the
color the colors are so vibrant like you
know how you go crazy but when you see
mercury in HD or mercury past and HD all
with that Sun in the back oh absolutely
believe it at some point there's gonna
be beautiful one of my moderns is gonna
turn into like a twitch app monitor and
when one of them is gonna be a the price
is gonna have to come down to get a 4k
HDR like all like 4k HDR all that type
of monitor yeah Mon is it so expensive I
was like before hit like now you can go
1440p HDR high-resolution all that stuff
is in there like g-sync and everything
that's not as bad but the 4k is like 2
grand yeah he is like $500 that makes
that price go crazy yeah but no that's
like that's the leap plate the HDR
ray-tracing 4k combo get that old lady
yeah buying my 60-inch Plasma upstairs
to go from that to a 4k OLED I'm just
gonna be like watching every movie like
like you already have a 4k blu-ray
player but by default with these systems
you ready we nuts yeah
you ready it's gonna be good a console I
can't wait me this is finally they're
gonna be you know they're gonna be
knocking sake so I'm so I think
hopefully they go d3 has to be if if
they don't build it for next gen I'm
gonna be upset because they're limiting
the potential of what the game can do
and I'm hoping their constraints dealing
now with like what they're currently
based in like ps4 and Xbox like if they
are building around that one they see
the constraints that gotta go next-gen
thank you so I think I think doctor you
just nailed it
I think the even if they want it to be
green right they say hey we're gonna
bring the old guys hundred with no
disease people like great
you got the SSDs that's gonna be the
problem right holding them back they're
not gonna have the same experience then
doc you said we got the addition of PC
which is a base that they didn't have
before to offset that then we have
another year of development on
next-generation console it the end that
the number one thing that you just said
which is from a design standpoint space
and structure they cannot maintain the
same old engine they can't they got they
have to use a new engine man they have
to do it so I think it's in our favor I
think it's in our favor that d3 will be
a next gen on now if they drop the ball
they talk about bringing them old do it
imma be I'm real set move yourself oh I
want to be very VIP I want to I want a
velvet rope on my destiny 3e um I wanna
bounce out front hey if they're gonna
get rid of all your old stuff it better
be fair a good thing right is that right
mommy your words back in your belly I
dropped my exotic rules go to you you
can retire room retire retire away you
give you that SSD that raytracer
oh whoa let's go how many probably think
are working on that right now like a
studio is trash yeah Luke that's why we
a single mark Noseworthy all um boy
young boys in there they are doing it ba
Baracus all of them is in there speed
official 80 is rocking out I think man
it's I can't wait I can't wait I can't
wait for it nice man
you know it's gonna be hey we hopefully
get the darkness the shot to set it up
zero if I drop all my guns but I knew it
see new hot yes Gladys there we go all
right so we have rambled on enough about
all that type of stuff but honestly the
speculation I didn't want to get to be a
downer in this episode yeah but we do
have to cover what's going on two things
happened one one of the tweets I sent
out was with regards to setting
expectations on the table yes so trials
last week had the issue where the
rewards were still not fixed for a lot
of people so the three five and seven
wins didn't happen for most anybody
flawless chest was still there mm-hmm
and then before the twelve came out just
earlier in the day it was pretty early
on on I think it was forget where but he
tweeted out - he just said this he said
to set expectations now the sixth Wahb
will not have specifics on numerous
items of feedback we numerous items of
feedback will be addressed we're nearing
approval on some action items for trials
which we've noted in previous a previous
table we've had a few meetings just this
week sorry to talk through many of the
major pain points the players are
feeling it sucks them and is like it's
nice just to see somebody even just like
a community person just to say it sucks
normally they're a little more like PR
SP he's just like them he's like it
sucks that things take time many of us
wish that we could turn around a day
later and say here's exactly what we're
doing how we're gonna do it knew when to
expect the patch but rushing fixes could
lead to more problems that could further
impact your enjoyment of the game
band-aid fixes could address the
feedback in short term but lead to
development issues in the future this is
their whole spaghetti code of stuff that
they've got that you keep hearing about
everything's so intertwined they can't
break anything that's why they even said
Polaris Lance isn't even getting fixed
for a little while because that's so
broken because they're saying other
things
might get affected by that mmm like
scout rifles or projectiles or it's
weird we want to make destiny to the
best it can be we don't want to break
hearts as noted in the original post we
want to have we want to create places
that inspire a friendship quite a bit of
Destiny to content still shines for new
players but we have work to do for those
that have been around for the long run
hope to have plans to share with you
soon will be loud and clear when we do
so well that was his thing of like you
know trials is what is it three weeks to
try it four weeks of trials we've had
now so four weekends of trials the
experience the cheating which some
people are saying is there but it is
I mean PC it's rampant rampant to some
point at least some people saying like
the high level people are seeing it
pretty consistently on their cars mm-hmm
so you had that come out that said the
expectation before even got the twelve
what did you think of that before we
even talked about the other topic I mean
I saw your tweet so I retweeted it and
that literally was my mindset coming in
because as much problems as we saw based
on the cadence based on what they said
you know they develop in to season cycle
I knew that they are not going to be
able to fix this trials thing you know
indicators that I want so easy the two
things gonna happen you gonna give it a
band-aid immediately or you tried you
wait and we get to the crux of the
problem hopefully that they can resolve
the only issue I have is I didn't like I
got a call them out on one thing I
didn't like when they were getting
called to carpet on their lack of
decisive cheating of banning member and
they they were very defensive II they
were like yo we've got an anti cheat
what the hell is it doing because
clearly people are going back in same
accounts people with bad
the story goes on so I'm not trying to
disrespect them because they are saying
that they have measures but this is
where and I got a shout out low no he
was on fire with this is I'm getting
this from him
you can't get mad say you got an touchy
and then blame and then save that blame
I say to the community oh you go fix it
you go report you do these extra steps
to let us know you know how like that's
your job
your job or the systems that you don't
have in place
you can't the game is already in a bad
state with trials with this trip with
this hacking RPC you can't then give the
responsibility to the player and say
it's your responsibility now to do these
extra steps to try to get us to Derrick
down cuz why is it not working on yours
that should be an automated process
there should be something that you
should have in place you know or working
towards and I know they can't tell us in
detail but I struggle with them having
to give us these three or four or five
extra steps like dude you're already
frustrated cuz you got cheated on you
got half you you lost your car because
of some fool now we got to sit there and
write a complaint form and now we got to
come on like that what bonds you okay I
love y'all but I don't like the way
y'all handle that they they could be
handled a little better that's all I'm
saying with that and um yeah you know at
the end of the day I respect the cadence
I understand that we've got a pandemic I
am being very understanding as far as
the time of when it can get done but you
cannot put that onus on the playerbase
to do all this extra stuff we clearly
the countermeasures you have are very
loose people are robbing your store and
they're going behind enemy lines and no
you can't tell people if you get a gun
and you stand on this corner let us know
if you saw those criminals come by no
fam get the National Guard down here but
that's where I'm at with it so I've rant
over but I had to say man that's fair
like I mean I've got my thoughts about
what we're gonna talk about next so
that's why I was on this one but it is I
mean they they are in a very tough spot
that was why last week when the tois
became out I read it and that was my
reply was like mm-hmm
guys we are in the middle of a worldwide
pandemic right now
and it is a serious thing people are
needing to stay at home because they're
you know things are not gonna be fixed
for a while and normal is not work
gonna happen till next year not to be
scary but it's like things are gonna be
weird so we have to set our expectations
of like development time how many games
have been delayed indefinitely speaking
of last of us is just like yeah we'll
figure out what nothing comes out when
you have something of that scale do that
you have to imagine a live service game
has a really tough spot to be in
they launched something to feature
people wanted did it come out correctly
no it didn't hit the nail on the head
now some people say elimination in and
of itself is fun the cheating the
rewards may not quite be what people are
looking for and the incentive to stay
around but the MOU didn't of itself is
kind of back and they now have the hard
problem trying to fix it from afar which
is not an easy thing to do but in turn
as you said when it comes to like
certain cheating and things like that
and be like hey the things we do have
are you know we've banned this many
number of people that you could even
just like how many people I would love
to see the number of people ban per day
right and just like see that type of
stuff to be like we are looking at this
we are working with these people to try
and work on other things I know they
can't show their hand per se as you
would say because they don't want to
tell other people how to do it
or how to get around it but on the other
side it's like they need more apparently
because what they're doing or the
biggest thing people are saying it's on
Steam people with the valve account bans
for however whenever still get to play
trials and that's the point where I
think it was asked across was just
saying mmm what a paywall on it I don't
care what I have to pay for this thing
I've put up to some way to pay for this
thing art always rests right yeah we all
agree member when we week when trials
was announced
we all agree we like don't know about
that free to play part we all kind of
cringed yep who's gonna pay for the
seasons anyway right and it doesn't have
to be that much but if you have the
people who pay and are relatively active
free or not hey there's this thing
trials I can go play crucible fine but I
can do the ultra-competitive thing I get
them pay for that right fine well like
if you have an active season past you
have access to trials that's all you
would have to do is you are a current
you own this current season
you can play trials the season all you'd
have to do and those little farmed
accounts that people just go switch over
and buy - yeah they stop and be a
seven-hour quest I want that like seven
I hate it so again this is them dropping
the ball you know I'm saying they've
gotten as far as getting back in but
again the thing is to make this issue
okay
this issue comes down to what they're
gonna have to do is they're going to
have to have team meetings which scheme
because clearly this is a joint effort a
task
I don't think Bungie can do this on
their own that's the vibe I'm getting
and I don't know like you've got to look
at what are the top look at what your
contemporaries are doing right look at
people that are in your space or in
similar spaces I believe like fortnight
and whatever you know Cod or whatever
like if it's a punkbuster or whatever
these applications are right you're
gonna have to partner up you're gonna
have to get you can do you have to
protect this game this is this is a
violation of the game this is people in
the space doing outrageous things
violating the integrity of your game you
have to do something on a bigger scale
now maybe that's what they are doing
maybe that's what the eventual goal is
they know they can't solve it with a
quick swoop but it we're getting it
because slowly but surely then PvP
numbers is going down slowly but surely
there's a slow creep you know say and
you don't want that to have thats the
last thing you want to have that's one
thing I know they do they are very say
they pay attention to those numbers so
they can't I know it's a two-season
cadence but I don't know if they can
wait to see this one this one has to you
have to act swiftly yeah thing is that's
when you hear so many content creators
and they'll say it mostly just cuz they
played PvP a lot more than I do
I haven't had as much but I mean all the
things they said it's like there are
ways to you know change the rewards on
the ticket or on your card to make the
help with like getting people out of lo
games if the low games are like one two
and three tokens and then literally if
you were like five six and seven was
like
in 20 and 30 tokens your incentive would
be to farm to the higher and that's
gonna help the lower level base then
when it coming the cheating is a thing
that takes time for them to investigate
a program for it and that's not an easy
thing to fix but like there are things
they can do like we're making an adept
weapon that's not gonna be an easy thing
to do to add another perk and get a
different skin and those things are
later additions but like right now for
the token farming people go make the
token farming stupidly more profitable
on the end of it you still the bottoms
not value don't be like 1 2 3 feel like
1 2 3 4 20 30 40 I don't care how many
tokens people have because you have
random roles in the first place okay go
go get some tokens out there and if
people like Grenadier Jake have 2000
trials tokens well guess what the dudes
done 55 flawless runs he probably should
have every weapon he needs because he's
earned it so right and I mean there
there are different ways to handle those
things but the cheating part is not
gonna be a quick fix adept weapons and
flawless rewards like go throw flawless
takes longer than a nightfall period go
through like two shots in there go throw
like five prisms go go make that thing
so good the people like man I'm going
flawless no question like that's what I
want to get to the beginning of making
things good for content that is a spot
aspirational content that is actionable
are we doing this now let's just do it
right already okay so the other thing
okay there are two things on the table
one there is going to be the Bungie
fundraiser stream Monday April 13th at
10:00 a.m. Pacific they will be doing
their fundraiser stream there is an
exclusive emblem during the stream
they're gonna tell you how to get it
ya don't have a clue it's a little vague
for this Thursday and here's your
donation levels I'll do this if it's
just like tune in I'm like alright kind
of a cool little honest I kind of like
it but don't know how to get it yet so
that is I do want to cover that one so
bungees fundraiser Monday April 13th 10
a.m. Pacific stay tuned we'll see what's
going on that one and yes we got the IO
bunker this week we talked about the
narrative speculate stuff mm-hmm a week
and a half from now
Grand Master nightfall
are coming oh yeah oh yeah we've heard
about them we've seen him in the
director coming April twist so I'm gonna
read off all the info and we're gonna
talk about it was good it this is why I
wanted to bring this up at the end so
the rest of the podcast is kind of fun
speculation more good evening for you
guys hopefully and people are like why
did you not start here this is why I
came to the podcast for
I'm sorry I should be very topics boy
you got me you get to talk it into a
story speculation is a hell of a lot
more fun than bashing something else
okay so grandmaster in a few weeks will
debut a new difficulty selection for the
ordeal called grandmaster it will test
your team's coordination communication
builds and skill like no other in the
activity destiny to date so they're
literally saying these are gonna be
harder than raids apparently oh here's a
look at a few goals we've had when
approaching grandmaster after we saw how
the rest of the ordeal was received
bullet point one grandmaster should be
based should build on master difficulty
but be significantly more challenging do
once you reach a certain bar the
challenge should be found completely in
perfecting your builds communication and
execution 3 oh the primary rewards
should be doled out on the initial
completion so it's not farmable or the
incentive is not forming for completion
should be the primary metric for success
rather than score or time or any or
another in-game activity metric like
killing all the champions fine
grandmaster should stress the top end of
build crafting six grandmasters should
be watchable watchable only what we want
to watch it to attempt grandmaster you
will need to be power level 1025 which
is 15 above the pinnacle power cane but
will be 25 power below the activity
which will be set at power level 1050
not 1060 we're also gonna have something
similar to contest mode when we
introduced for crown of sorrow you will
get no extra advantage for being higher
than power level 10 25 so you have to be
10 25 but you don't need to be any
higher than 10 25 we wanted to acquire
require a mixture of pinnacle rewards
and artifact power to get you prepared
for this but not make you feel like you
had to put it in ton of extra hours of
over leveling the activity mmm-hmm get
back to that
we're introducing some new modifiers
along with some familiar way you have
favorite looting the Amish even chill
wipes you are sent back to orbit and
limited pool types you start with a
small pool of shared team revives and
you get more every time you kill a
champion we don't want to spoil
everything so there are a few other
wrinkles to let you discover as go slide
does this sound like really challenge so
far
we hope it does and as a reward you'll
have increased chances of being awarded
exotic armor and master work materials
but the main drought of the mode is the
new seal and the title available for
beating each of the Grand Master ordeal
strikes once during the season Coghlan
we want this to be one of the most
challenging titles to get but we want to
be approachable for anyone to try puts
in the time a dedication with their team
during a given season whoa lot there you
sell what you are cuz I'm gonna do yeah
I know I know you about to go in um look
we we felt we're a little nervous when
we heard this announcement initially
right what could they do is it just
gonna be negative modifiers
walk away you don't boom boom um this
surprised me child to definitely
Prescott by facepalm was on deck too
because I'm like okay you want us to do
this high in extremely you know
difficult activity and you're not giving
any different rewards besides the shards
and you're not even given a guaranteed
exotic you're given the hope of like why
should I do this why should I be people
watch me for your enjoyment my pain and
for your enjoyment like loss is a lot
this is a lot of pain and you know they
talk about wrinkles that are gonna be
added that they're gonna you know - is
it gonna be more negative like oh
there's like 11 of them if it's anything
like it's in game this is literally just
this is for swag bro this Baron right
Rick I'll keep this very short
this is that it this is not it I'm sorry
that you cannot introduce this new
you've not given any exclusive you mean
the title sounds cool
but then you got the limited nature of
this thing but we're following this
again and it's like look I'm gonna watch
to do is I want to do it fine you know
if you dis excites you please don't take
my disrespect personally this is
something I am NOT doing I do not care
about that you are not giving me no
incentive to go in there and do anything
and all it just seems is pain so I'll be
content to grind the same shards you
grinding the shame the conquer reduce
this for the conquer do right all that
yoga
I'll be right to levels below grinding
the same thing over and over and getting
there when I get there yeah I could keep
that title I am good I'm comfortable in
my skin that I am NOT a conqueror that
they are but that's it but i'ma let you
go I was surprised they missed the mark
learners to be honest this really seemed
very very very light very very yeah I
can't cosign this man your name is not
on that application you're not putting
that signature on that second line
artist now where we gonna it's the last
point before I give it where we're going
right now a season of the worthy isn't
it a good place as far as a hierarchy of
expansions and at the beginning I was
kind of defending them and you felt it
you will put me on you were like are
done with this bunker what else we gonna
do before word you've been hinting to me
that this is not Blaine oh right yeah
you've not been feeling it and I'm like
nah we got surprises you know who this
is strike three the trousers bit of miss
the bounty hell and then this is like
three men and this is to out like Oh
season like it's so bad I'm playing
Final Fantasy I'm playing all these
other
when neo last night I see you or Neil
it's like yeah this this is not it y'all
so yeah
I'm sorry season worthy right now is
shaping up what was the plan what was
the curse I can I think I'm Cyrus
actually better yeah we gonna have to
are we get into drifter and black Armory
territory black armor is better than
well call me had a raid
yeah yeah we had seasoned it adrift the
territory but I think season just it
might be but at least we have reckoning
we had a new vote we had gambit primes
you know we had that we had the
loop-de-loop
we had the merry-go-round loop now shift
it was but this this literally as it
shapes up season of the worthy is not
worthy could arguably be the worst DLC
or expansion or whatever you want to
call content right now this is really
looking unless something cataclysmic
happens right now what I hate to say cuz
trials debuted on this thing but yeah he
is all yours but I'm gonna let you teach
good season it'll bore these savage
goody okay so these are my thoughts and
this is we're gonna wrap up the podcast
that's why this is at the end so you can
leave with the bad team so multiple
things that have been watching Twitter
different reactions different people
keep bringing up multiple points on this
day he's like oh yeah I like to slide
down to boy band now you got chords to
run into my brother was pissed about
that he's like dude you ruined the slide
the iron bunker they ruined the slide
fire yeah first I'm gonna be going
through the levels here so mmm just in
the post we've got they want this to be
watchable what is that
it's your twitch stream did you know
there's no belts there's no scoring
there's no rewards there's no there's no
incentive to be repeatable the people
who actually finish a week's Grand
Master nightfall
when they're done with that they're like
shelf till next week they're not
okay so that's like one and done not
repeatably watchable so strike one they
want to stress top in build crafting
okay so like we're all gonna be using
the same bill with divinity and as
managing is not gonna be like how much
your stats are gonna be it's like okay
can you have divinity line up a couple
izanagi's somebody's gonna have a tether
somebody's gonna have a well you might
have a bubble as backup so you don't die
or can res somebody if you even have a
res soakin up the bringing in res tokens
which people hate from raids by the way
like res tokens and raids something a
lot of people would like to see go away
because you literally I've been in the
moment where we got screwed on garden of
salvation opening day by arrest oaken we
would have finished the encounter
couldn't finish it cuz of a res dokkan
because we ran out so you're bringing in
limiting revives extinguish has been in
night falls that's not surprising right
but limited revives I've seen people
just like when that thing came out the
people who were like they spent two
hours in a nightfall just to finish a
master mm-hmm but they were like
hunkered in a corner sitting by the hind
this thing to be like trying to peck
away at this one guy and they were
getting like rezzed I'm like okay so if
people do get in a pinch you're screwed
right straight up they score isn't a
thing mmm I don't even know if they're
gonna score it at all
apparently they may not time the thing
no time in a stressing that time and is
not gonna be part of their mechanic nor
master difficulty already most people
farm legend so warden of it I think last
week was on was farmable people would
much rather farm legend and get the
prisms and go by the shards as opposed
to farm master due to like the
difficulty being that much more annoying
and if you look at the modifiers in
there now it's just like take master
crank it up if they're on nine they're
going to about twelve on the pain and
what difficulty thanks so yeah they want
you to communicate okay
so the things the things wrong with this
for multiple people shout out to teasing
teddy we had him on the podcast before
shot to Teddy so up and
now we've seen in the game it's 1060
parallel so people like alright I wanna
get as high as I feasibly can to grind
up there and be ready because we know
these things are gonna have insane
modifiers from what we're seeing so I'm
gonna do six million bounties a week to
try and get my power level up there as
high as possible I am level 1045 going
into this week okay if anything above
1025 doesn't matter are you freaking
kidding me baby that's it that is stage
one if this is two things both are wrong
one either they knew this and I let
people grind backs and spend countless
hours grinding bounties which makes them
hate your game a little bit more when
they do it by the way wolf so they spent
all these times then they tell you all
that grinding you did it doesn't matter
nothing zero work on the bounties the
other side is the fact that they didn't
know and then they do this last minute
and they then they devalue that the
amount of time people have put in the
game for that thing they throw it in
later to put an artificial difficulty
cap in there as opposed they here's
another champion okay we can't put
champions everywhere so how do we make
this harder okay we're gonna cap you on
a power level period so the constant
rule nightfall this is cool ya know it's
a contest rule just like a raid but you
were hard capped and then the other side
of that is so somebody I was reading on
reddit somebody was like so you
introduced the artifact that lets me get
as high as I feasibly want but in the
aspirational content it doesn't matter
mmm okay so you've got the power level
issue of either screwing with people's
time for the investment because you can
pull up this is if you guys ever want to
do this it's kind of scary to see how
much time people into this thing but if
you go to destiny tracker you go to
leaderboards and you look at the power
level yeah highest level people in the
game you what dude has been going nuts
his name is dark Lancelot oh he is a
power level
10:57 10:54 and 1054 between his
characters now if you guys want to know
what that math is your armor caps by
pinnacles at 10:10 so his artifact right
now is plus 57 no I'm sorry plus 47 and
if you don't know the experience curve
is expo
intial if you're trying when people were
trying to get up to a thousand they
their next level was 6 million
experience oh right now I'm at like 1.6
and I'm like plus 15 it was six seven
he's probably even higher than that
there's other people at 10:48 10:47 1046
1044 you're looking at an artifact bonus
of 30 or more to get these people up
there and they literally had to get plus
15 like I have been and I haven't even
done pinnacles if I didn't pinnacles and
I was whereas that I'd be done
I'd be 10:25 and I would be done without
having to go through bounty grind for
weeks for weeks
here's the thing I was saying that he
said it fast I think he said again these
are made for the gigs the glass daddles
because they know they were straight I
agree I guess the intention was let's be
real I'm not justifying I'm just saying
I know what the intention was the
attendee intention was we've got our
hardcore super you know hardcore guys
that one less columnar you know the 5%
of the 1% right that aren't very bored
right now right they they feel bored
they've done everything you know you
guys are finished so now it's like well
let's get dub the stream we'll get
attention on the game but the execution
is still bad and and again why are they
gonna do this for these level but these
type of rewards I mean little words yet
oh god like is it gonna be 10 shots is
it gonna be like gonna be like - maybe
you know you you can't but what was my
cursor dropped abroad it was well it was
a joke
2 to 2 tokens and those two blues from
that public event yeah - blues that's
what this like come on come on
no no you've got so you've got the power
level issue of not telling people soon
enough or a late decision that basically
is a slap in the face of the people who
did put in the time hmm okay so then you
do that okay so they want it to be
watchable or farmable okay you're saying
the dados the glads esoteric whoever
yep esoteric still gonna sell it with
that hand tied behind us back loop but
you'll find a way
mm yeah I don't know how it's gonna be
crazy but you they do it once what is
their incentive to go race this thing to
do it again like they said the main
rewards are gonna come on the first drop
they said they had a couple of the
wrinkles in there as well and I'm sure
late GLAAD and Chevy they'll do it I'm
not surprised dad in math class they'll
do it right but your incentive to do it
what do you get so you get a higher
chance not even a guaranteed exotic it's
not gonna be master worked which it
should do wait Dave confirm is not
master I mean I don't know but I'm
assuming they just set a higher chance
of dogs dropping they don't say it's
gonna be a master at exotic that should
happen if you if you do get a Masonic
every exotic that drops should be master
worked period for this level of crazy
now maybe on the other side they're
worried about out shining trials so
here's this new aspirational pde content
and they're like well if you can go in
there and get masterwork exotics maybe
that might be incentive too far but you
can't get the same thing in trials from
the flawless chest which still might be
harder to do because then is trials
worthwhile if so that might be be the
balance there we can't wait to see
someone getting up exotic from the Grand
Master with a 60 stat role Oh
oh my god a 50 oh yeah it's gonna be
like a 58 and people are yeah you go by
yours or pinnacle in Graham and you get
a better role like mm-hmm that new uh so
that's an issue and you're just getting
shards like master working materials
there's so much wrong with infusion and
master working and crap right now just
the fact that that's the only other
thing you get you don't get an exclusive
anything maybe like some brightness give
us some brightness you know how many
people would actually farm that crappy
brightness of silver sir hilarious
[Music]
sounds like so you've got rewards
not not um it was the episode of How I
Met Your Mother I was watching recently
and it's got Jason Segel and it's got
like they're they're working something
out with some people and like every time
they like kind of sin to their version
of like okay well how about this and
he's like not good enough and he's like
cracking a whip and they're looking
through this listing not good enough
he's just like cracking the whip and I'm
just like don't have incentive to do
this one yeah well if you don't have
like that's a problem right if you don't
have I don't want to I don't want to do
this because it's gonna be a pain in my
absolute just body and soul for
something that I'm like what if you do a
grandmaster and you don't even get a
night fault or you don't even get an
exotic drop you just get like two shards
and you're like let me let me let me cut
I would shut it down and go take a walk
oh yeah it'd be done I would be like
Kashuk leaves on fire right now because
here's the thing this is where they
really tone-deaf right now I'm sorry I
gotta call it because think about this
think about how the community was
galvanized with the nightfall last week
because it was a glitch giving double
rewards right we were like y'all we shut
low let's get in there let's do it
you don't saying like that's that kind
of stuff the community gets excited
about this no this is not it this is not
a go this is and the scary part about it
is I am shocked they press send on this
like someone should have pulled someone
to the side and say yo they're dead no
this is this is not it you've got to do
something you got to make adjustment you
got to make tweaks you cannot ship this
as it this this is a very bad look and
and I'm worried that this this is a is
one of those weird kind of mistakes like
you should know better but like this use
it you should know better you can't do
that you can't it all I'm all I'm hoping
and this is even I know it's not even to
me that much of a hope but with the
sentence that says yeah we don't want a
small everything as there are a few
other wrinkles
we let you discover well it's just gonna
be even harder I'm sure more champion
I'm trying to champion it with art some
people's with the energy shields on top
of them I don't know what crazy crap
you're gonna throw at you
this is tone-deaf this is tone-deaf this
is a botch
they say go and go well when is winners
drop witness drops first though we can
have same day as guardian Games and I'm
not even holding my breath for that one
either
this season is like way down the totem
pole man Oh bunker gate killing me here
trials the best hack city hack city
trials that's a rough these are dark it
feels like we have an open month on the
calendar we don't know what's out there
there might be a secret hidden thing
people of date of mind but if that's
like a quest maybe that that might what
else is there
yeah it's it's like a spooky band I hate
to say it yeah games on the docket right
now backlog I'll be hit my back lock
picked up Final Fantasy 7 remake I've
been blade listen you got things to do
until they sort this thing out man
because at the end of the day it's just
like you know we love this game and you
know it's just it's just like I said
this is just a couple of it's two things
going on this is a tactical mistake
we're not excusing it but couple that
with pandemic low low stress I mean low
arm bandwidth yeah
then can't make based on their cadence
they've told us they they work two
seasons in tandem right so this and
whatever's next right is locked in kind
of right is it's just the light end of
this one is like so this is will be
helping what they learn from this one
hopefully is going into September
probably might be like for final wraps
but yeah
season 11 was whatever they learned from
dawn like dawn helped shape like the
early feedback and dawn is probably
helping shape 11 right but yeah
so worthy and the next one is joint
together problem yeah I mean yeah this
one's like being yeah they're about six
months open tell you any farther than
that yeah yeah tip this this is rough
baby but it's like how do you put it out
there and say hey you're gonna do do
grandmaster with contest
there's not even a friggin emblem and
I'd honestly don't care about like
that's the thing it's like I'm tired of
emblems yeah those are like those don't
show that much I mean you if you paired
up with somebody was like hey you did
the day one Garden of salvation that's
cool mm-hmm but I was like even titles
now I have six or seven I can pick from
if I put another one on my list of
conquer it sounds cool shadow sounds
cool almighty sounds a little pompous
but it still sounds kind of cool
um LEDs making a good point now let's
compare he said to put in perspective
this is paralleled undying I'm dying or
now and I had vex offensive only right
yep it had it had it had an activity and
that activity don't it wasn't limited
that was pretty much it
monsters and legendary loss sectors and
stuff like that that's what this okay I
might say ceases where these better than
sees another if you if you take undying
and we take a guy everything else
Shadow King vex offensive public events
because you have to take the raid out of
that as well because that's like the
shadow keys so I mean so undying
probably just because it but that's
always hard because you have this giant
asterisks that it long yeah with shadow
keys shadow gonna be the biggest thing
like this season exclusives literally if
you bought shadow keep you got it to
there's you know additional purchases
like that one almost doesn't count the
argument I would say just because it's
like on that buffer below like yeah you
don't count you're fine like yeah we
know
but yeah it's down there with it no I
was like grandmaster for me just hurts
because
10:25 type of contact I was like this is
kind of mine but it was like what's my
incentive you don't get a guaranteed
masterwork exotic you don't even get a
chance at like the double exotic traps
we just got done see and we're like
those are cool you could get you know in
a difference they haven't confirmed
right what if they said it with the the
rewards let's see let's read the exact
but what's the exact set the primary
will war it says plural to shards we
have increased the chance of being
awarded exotic armor and metalworking
horses as a reward increased chances
this is literally bragging rights that
is all this is I tried but I was like
and this pains me because if you were
like hey if exotic armor that does drop
will be fully masterwork dude be like it
like that's it that would at least be
like it sets it a little apart you're
guaranteed a fully masterwork exotic
there's so many stat world distributions
and there's like 30 per character you
could be like I in there hard enough to
run you're not gonna farm them but it
was like you get a fully mess where you
believe you at a fifty five five five
shard it to good two two three four golf
ball well I mean then you're just gonna
be a master working your other stuff
you've got anyway mmm
but most people just farmed it all out
as it is the people so the thing about
master working materials they're a pain
point for about 80% of the player base
and then the people who play a lot in
our crazy hardcore and the people who
are probably gonna pay this anyway they
don't need them right so your your
materials for master working are
annoying because they take a casual
person or somebody who only has you know
three days a week like you know captain
McFly he's like dad
he's got three days a week to play
master work materials are probably
pretty sparse and thin because he
doesn't have that much time so for him
they're just an annoyance and he may
never master work armor that often on
the other side the people who are
probably gonna look at this are gonna
get a beginning materials they don't
need because they already can farm the
master they've got enough golf balls and
go in maxed out as it is so half the
rewards that the people who are gonna
play this get don't matter and then the
other side the exotic armor they
probably have a build that they need and
if you're going in with a build already
you probably have the exotic whether
it's Luna factions whether whatever your
exotic is you have it set up probably
master worked so the drop you get is
probably as decent okay so literally
both rewards for the people who are
gonna do this are not incentive yeah so
then it's truly a title checklist its
complete yet like it's literally just
private right it's bragging rights be a
stream bought a hardcore guys with
Wacken since it's just a it's just that
the intent we get what they're trying to
do but unfortunately it's just yeah man
Oneiric skeptical Yasu that there is
that's also some lovely rich that's
what's up
salute to him man yeah and you know it's
gonna be interesting to see when this
thing debuts how you're gonna start with
the club it's gonna be yeah i can t
defend it's just a low point this is a
very low point i know it was not thought
about that's and that's that's one of
the things they talked about like luke
even talked about and this is kind of
where i'm gonna wrap my piece on this up
go for talks about aspirational content
and if you want aspirational content of
builds and things of that nature you
need a game that you actually can work
on builds because right now i can't find
a whole bunch of resilience and have 250
resilience so i'm this ultra tanky guy
and then in the back there's a warlock
who's got a lot of recovery so he's
getting his healing grenade up more and
more and more and more to run through
and there's not there's not the
diversity of loadouts enough between
stats and classes and things you have
minimal differences in builds and
everybody's probably going to use the
same load of weapons of divinities
izanagi's you're probably gonna have a
couple other things in there for
primaries just whatever works and you
got to deal with champions and you can't
even throw exotics on or exotic mods or
mods on exotic weapons so
well the aspirational content that
you're making right now is unfortunately
to a point if it's just gonna be adding
as many annoying pain points personally
as opposed to champions which are in
theory at least a mechanic and not an
artificial power lab which is office
champions in I summer annoying could use
tweaks like a barrier who puts up a
shield and can still shoot through it
while you have to shoot him that's not
you kind of right yeah but on the other
side your rewards as well if you're
gonna make aspirational content for
anything and this goes for trials as
well if you're gonna make aspirational
content that is gonna be a pain in the
butt
gonna take seven wins without a loss to
do with cheaters disconnects and
everything else by the time you actually
finish set activity and get that reward
the juice needs to feel like it's worth
the squeeze and right now neither piece
of the worthy of the big aspirational
content feels like it is worth the
effort a depth weapons aren't their
master worked armor from either play you
could get a fully masterwork legendary
piece of gear from trials you get a
fully masterwork exotic from Grandmaster
nightfall mmm at least to set it apart
but neither do that you go heresy and
you get a fully masterwork thing yep
that that's been the theme season that a
worthy it ain't worth it it's like what
you had you literally you meant your
mindset when you log in is why why am i
doing it should I do this why should I
do it trial should I do it why is there
gonna be each each part of the game is
not as not worthy to do if the most
ironic name right these are the worthy
with nothing is worth your while to do I
hate to call it bro but it's just you
know they in they've they've aired on
this side of caution and and and we've
seen this pattern with you know what the
aspirational content like recluse and
you know things and everything all that
stuff that was hard to get and then
making easier and you know I get it you
try to target that casual base that
plays the most
you know I'm saying and I get it but at
the end of the day you know you're
missing the mark and unfortunately just
like how cursor Osiris they had to learn
the hard way when to put the playerbase
say yo I'm out we're not doing this this
is not why are we doing it we're not
gonna do it we're out and then they get
it and then you know it they're starting
about destiny is just it's always these
peaks and valleys and you just get mad
that it has to happen because we feel
like it shouldn't you know I'm saying
and this is where we are this is a low
Valley we gonna have to power through
you know and just it is what it is
right now it's just right now it's it's
not a go so for guys who are enjoying
their grind
please do grind for me I still enjoy
trials when it don't when I don't get
hacked and glitched but I still love the
most so much and I'm having fun when I
do play it I do my bunkers casually I
jump in I jump out you know I'm saying I
set my little things and then I keep it
moving I got my other gays it didn't you
know once the next stuff comes out the
next story beat I'll be right back in
the mix right there but right now this
is definitely new this is a low point
yeah this this i don't even think should
be coming out right now
I'd rather mm-hmm it's doesn't seem
fitting of the right time and then the
reward if they don't have the bandwidth
to make their awards different you can't
do exclusive nitro at fault gear or a
nightfall armor or we joked about before
Grand Master armor start making stuff
with like 12 in like no way to set it
apart if you don't have the bandwidth
for it just dumping it out now leaves a
sour taste and it's the weird thing if
you that first impression of Grand
Master night falls if they do revamp it
later on how many people are still gonna
be like okay yeah listen one thing about
us though as much as I'm complaining we
come back you know I know that I I know
we I know a lot of us do but it's still
just the initial light yeah QA of like
are we are we this this is the the sign
off that dotted line got signed and
we're okay
this is this is where it's going like I
I want to know the discussions to be
like this is what we
have this is all we can push out right
now mm-hmm and if that's what it is I
don't know but I want to I want to know
how the fight about this I agree I agree
I agree with you because you're right
you're spot on e at the end of the day
we understand bandwidth right yeah we'll
give them a pass on that we all
understand a pandemic is going on on top
of that right we get it
this is not affected because they chose
to make these rules right they chose
this does it this isn't a resource issue
this isn't we had time enough to make it
they chose this decision on how this is
going this this thing is gonna play out
and that is what we can't excuse cuz
this was not thought out correctly this
was this was a misstep so that's why
this one they gotta get they gotta get
that one they gotta get the blame on
this one because this has nothing this
is you thought in your mind this is
going to be exciting
you thought people were gonna be like
yeah we can't wait
yo how are you gonna get three shards
today baby let's go like no no one's
doing that no one then you contest the
ruled you you kill people's grind yeah
they did they they thought they thought
they were going for a petty uh you know
what you call it raid flow they thought
they would be they thought people gonna
get excited for that big contest version
of the raid and they thought people
don't get twitch streams popping I know
what the thought process is but I mean I
mean Kevin pretty well summed it up
right there reckoning has more incentive
to play right now than these do you know
you can get spare rations or non hunger
how about give us an exclusive harbor
set so it just cosmetically looks good
you you came give us a talk or armor set
right give me a sentiments okay for the
first leg the first fighter aces are a
set of armor ornaments that are just bad
chrome on it right put some put some
glow on it like make dumb dudes who did
this you like y'all that's again that's
thinking it through like I just don't
understand who said finished
who
signed over say yup that's it nah that's
not it
you even have like trials that glows
geta are set from the grand master night
fault that could like be farmable in
there and then each week you beat it you
have fire coming out of your shoulders
cuz you are literally like the clunker
like pauldron pauldron coming out
everybody looking like man we'd have
been hot what about you know what yo I
want to fall for that same man that's
ability I got some bounties to do guys I
will be like mm-hmm
so that's all I got and I think and on
this note hey hey I know - we yeah I
gotta bounce - I was like in bungee if
you guys do listen to this mm-hmm we
love this game we love it and believe me
we are so excited for what the future is
gonna hold because I love where the
story is going absolutely the story has
been the most positive thing to sort of
narrow the beats these seasons have been
amazing and it's like and I'm enjoying
that it's just mm-hmm things like this
when it comes out it kind of hurts
because I want to look forward to it and
sadly I'm I'm honest I'm not I was like
and that sucks for me to say it so you
know I mean and I've learned now with
this season structure when I'm not happy
let me catch up for these couple of
games get the backlog knocked down and
not coming in on more casual pace and
then once they get back I'm right back
you know like right now I'll just log it
in on Fridays I do my little trials here
in there I do my bunker when I get a
chance and that's it and I sign out
until we get more of what we're really
looking for well that's all I think
we've got for the week again the Bungie
stream for the fundraiser is gonna be
Monday at noon tune in or watch
somewhere to figure out how we get this
emblem we will just have to see but as
for today I feel like that wraps it up
and you guys as we wrap this thing up
try not to run I do always like to go
raid a destiny player when we get done
with this thing I've got a good one to
go raid when we get done so when we get
the
I will send you guys over so hang tight
in stream got a blow up somebody's
channel so but before we go kognito let
me know what you got coming for the week
or weekend or what are you even up to or
just where they can find you absolutely
know on twitter and iron Lords podcast
on youtube please check us out Sunday's
the Lord's Day we will be having
returning old friends to the rum J
Fonzarelli content creator really could
he's on the r-tx podcast one of the top
podcast in the game right now these guys
always kill it and J Franz really is
good people we're gonna talk and he's a
he's a big Final Fantasy nut like myself
we're gonna talk about that we got to
talk about that PS 5 and all the stuff
that's going on in gaming so check us
out Sundays 1:00 p.m. Eastern also
analyst podcast please check my brother
King David the king of statues if you
are a marvel fan if you're a DC fan if
you love these iconic characters he's
got amazing statues these things look
lifelike man check them out when you get
a chance on of course Lords a gaming
dotnet and you be proud of it cuz I'm
not gonna say I'm gonna say it now but
I'm not gonna say it oh I love podcast I
said the best day in fact 35 days is on
Fridays I said you know I appeal but say
that's my new mantra he says I don't say
it enough I say it on other platforms
now he'd be very proud of me that I see
you can say it all over the other
platforms we're just we good here but
you shout to the elastic shout to the
chat yo yo yo or fire all you guys back
give us energy
great discussion great points great
feedback love chatting with cha man of
course e my bro always on fine neo metal
dag your brother for holding me that's
easy kognito did say it on the other
place see but video better know to be
down but I gave I gave this shoutout and
I also a lot of people been giving us
positive feedback on last word and it
really means a lot that you listen to us
when we go into our rants and stuff that
we love we still love this game
regardless it's like I know my today is
gonna be this long I'm sorry if there
would it's that great discussion but
that's all that's a that future console
building speculation was kind of
interesting okay who I wanted to send
you guys to is actually got a be right
back up right now so I'm gonna send you
guys over to Connie actually so so for
me if you guys are looking for me
I have been playing neo actually a
decent amount so working my way through
a Souls game Final Fantasy I'm really
debating how to play this and I actually
kind of wanted to ask you this is a wrap
welcoming yes I am working through neo
if I don't finish it I feel like I'll
never finish it cuz it's so it's like a
partial yeah I'm not even that far
through but I feel like it's ways to go
but for me Ida made it on and I don't
know if this is dumb my brother said
just skip it
I'm honestly curious to play the old
Final Fantasy 7 through to like finish
Midgard that's the place I've heard this
is through and then turn around like
behind it and go play the remake to
experience the more 5 hours and 40 hours
kind of thing and kind of like if they
space this thing out over time play the
part that I think it's through in the
wind and old game and then experience
the remake version kind of piecemeal it
alright here's the thing it's not a bad
idea
I actually don't disagree with it's
actually a unique way of looking at it
because you're new to the series right
of them so I will say this um the only
the only issue I would have with that
and this is just if this is a personal
question you only you would know is that
can you do with those graphics cuz I
have to go play Chrono Trigger again so
yeah okay so if you can deal with the
graphics of the original Final Fantasy 7
cold you know I will say like it's just
a little bit Mario Super Mario RPG I
also play that like now so you're a
retro graphics are you gonna be fine
yeah that's actually a good idea because
you'll get you what it is is you know
whole a lot of the scenes will hold more
weight for you you know I'm saying you
know yeah you could you could do that
you get all the way up to make hard
stuff like that and all I will say is
this the the stuff that there was stuff
that was in Final Fantasy 7 that may
have been a five or ten minute or busy
that is now an entire open-world like
four to five hour thing yes like a five
hour part of the game the first five
hours and people like how are you gonna
do this and it's like a here yes
so 45 hours and they'll yeah yeah
literally and the last one I'll say is
just for the purists this is more of an
adaptation than a one-to-one yeah mix
way if you're looking for like not you
but not someone yeah so for me I'm
loving I'm like yo this is nudists this
is different like okay they should we
still got the structures basic structure
the same but Dave made a taking
liberties so yeah but I would say yeah
you could do that and this way you can
hold out you don't have to buy you still
do you kneel you take you do Final
Fantasy 7 original at your own thing
you'll be fine
yeah it's just an idea but granted if
I'm gonna be if I'm gonna be in the now
there's need to shut everything down and
play remake like today that would be the
way to something no I mean no life we
will see so alright so yeah for me
Ibanez twitch Twitter YouTube
you guys know where to find me as well
you guys haven't subbed and also for
both of us for iron Lords podcast and my
youtube channel if you are if you aren't
subscribed go subscribe but if you are
subscribed please hit the alert bell as
well yes yeah err YouTube's algorithms
always being funky and apparently just
even more so that YouTube like once the
Bell so yeah those will help get our
videos to you so it's always appreciated
I know it's notifications you may have a
lot of them but it helps us and we
appreciate the support from you guys so
this is episode 98 holy crap whoa - away
we are working on a hundred being
awesome we've got a guest lined up there
that honestly very hopeful everything
comes Rumble potentially got a guest for
next week gonna talk nice right after
we're nice and then yeah dude 100 is so
close and it's only April so two other
things yeah stay safe and if you have to
leave your house just please be smart
please be aware of your face cover your
face if you can and don't do it like
just don't coat don't go to groups yeah
play groups yeah stay with me just game
stay home watch movies dream its
the one thing you've ever need to do and
wash your damn hands people's that too
that was the other one was gonna say but
yeah doors and wash your damn hands make
sure you get between here and get the
thumb get the nails as well you guys
actually won the marker over if you guys
haven't seen him he's a cool science
nasty youtuber he's done the glitter
package he did one with that stuff you
put on your hands in the places people
miss I said race we in the hand awesome
but like around the nails and the
fingers yes yes that twenty thirty
Seconds especially if you go out and get
groceries oh yeah only go to town from
late mid forearm down just yeah go for
it so you contaminate yo it literally
just touch my face right now cuz your
glasses if you're home and you've washed
your hands you don't have to wash your
hands six thousand times at home but if
you go out definitely make sure you
spend the time to clean up we have this
excuse expensive hair disgust buddy
honestly at this point in the time like
that is one of those things like won't
be shaking hands with anybody for quite
a while and that's real it's just mm-hmm
yeah so that's all we got for this one
thank you guys longer than expected of
course as always but you guys are
amazing
yeah so for episode 98 thank you for the
discussion hopefully you guys enjoyed
sorry to leave on a sour note but stay
safe stay awesome enjoy your time in
gaming and just keep yourself saying if
you're not having fun and one thing go
have fun somewhere else some games we
will see you guys next week looking
forward to hundred with all of y'all and
for both of us here on the podcast it
has been the last words were